ALL RIGHT, EVERYONE, WELCOME TO
OUR JOINT HEARING TODAY FOR WITH
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY,
SELECT COMMITTEES ON THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR. TODAY OUR
JOINT HEARING IS TITLED BARRIERS
AND SOLUTIONS TO NONPROFIT
PARTICIPATION IN STATE
GOVERNMENT. TODAY'S HEARING
CONTINUES ON THE WORK THAT OUR
SELECT COMMITTEES IN BOTH HOUSES
HAVE IDENTIFIED AS AREAS THAT
HAVE POSED SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES TO NONPROFITS ON HOW
OUR GOVERNMENT PROCESSES CAN BE
MODERNIZED OR AND IMPROVED
RELATED TO THE OUTCOMES, BOTH
FOR NONPROFITS AND THE OUTCOMES
DESIRED FOR OUR STATE. OUR GOAL
IS TO BEGIN THIS CONVERSATION ON
HOW WE CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT THE CRITICAL WORK THAT
NONPROFITS DO FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND STATEWIDE. I
WANT TO THANK ALL, YOU KNOW,
SPECIAL THANKS TO THE NONPROFITS
AND STATE ENTITIES FOR ENGAGING
WITH US IN THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION. I DO LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM OUR PANELISTS
ABOUT WAYS THAT WE CAN
STRENGTHEN, IMPROVE, AND PARTNER
TO MOVE FORWARD. I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
JOINT HEARING IS BEING HELD JUST
A FEW DAYS BEFORE AUGUST 17TH
AND AUGUST 17TH IS NATIONAL
NONPROFIT DAY. SO HAPPY NATIONAL
NONPROFIT DAY IN ADVANCE TO THE
NONPROFITS PRESENCE. THOSE THAT
ARE LISTENING, THOSE THAT ARE
FOLLOWING AND OF COURSE, TO ALL
NONPROFITS AT THE STATE
GENERALLY FOR INCREDIBLE WORK
AND COMMITMENT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. I HAVE THE REALLY
GREAT HONOR AND PLEASURE TO HAVE
AN INCREDIBLE CHAIR ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE, AND I WANT TO
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART,
WHO IS GOING TO SAY A FEW WORDS
AND IS ALSO A CHAIRING THIS
CONVERSATION AND LEADING THIS
CONVERSATION ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE. THANK YOU, CHAIR LEMON, I
REALLY APPRECIATE OUR
PARTNERSHIP AND ORGANIZING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE PANELISTS, THE
NONPROFIT STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
JOINING US TODAY. OUR DISTRICT
IS HOME TO OVER 2000 NONPROFITS.
WE HAVE ONE OF THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATIONS OF NONPROFITS PER
CAPITA IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I UNDERSTAND VERY
WELL THE IMPACT AND BENEFITS
THAT NONPROFITS HAVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ACROSS THE
WORLD. THE FOCUS OF THIS HEARING
IS ON THE VITAL ROLE NONPROFITS
PLAY IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE IN
PARTNERING WITH STATE
GOVERNMENT. IT'S ONE OF THE IT'S
ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
AND FIND POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS TO
THESE BARRIERS. I LOOK FORWARD
TO LEARNING FROM THE PANELISTS
ON HOW WE CAN STRENGTHEN THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
AND NONPROFITS, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
OUR FIRST PANEL. WE ARE FOCUSING
ON MODERNIZATION AND
SPECIFICALLY MODERNIZATION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
CHARITABLE TRUSTS REGISTRY. SO
WE HAVE THREE PANELISTS THAT
WILL HAVE JUST ABOUT TEN MINUTES
EACH. WE WILL TIME IT FOLKS, BUT
WE HAVE ELIZABETH KIM, SENIOR
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CHARITABLE TRUSTS SECTION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. WE HAVE DAVID ELLER,
REGISTRAR OF THE REGISTRY OF
CHARITIES AND FUNDRAISERS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, AND JON JONES,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COCOA
KIDS. SO WE WILL BEGIN, WITH
EITHER ONE OF YOU, OR WE CAN GO
IN ORDER, YOU KNOW, MISS KIM, IF
YOU'D LIKE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND I WANTED TO INTRODUCE
THE, OVER HERE WE HAVE. AND
ANTHONY LIU HERE, BUT HE'S JUST
HERE FOR SUPPORT. HE'S NOT GOING
TO BE SPEAKING TODAY. OKAY.
THANK YOU. SO I WANTED TO START
WITH AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
PRESENTATION TODAY. AND THESE
ARE THE TOPICS THAT WE ARE
PLANNING TO COVER. AND IT'S
BASED ON THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU
POSED TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE ABOUT WHAT YOU WANTED TO
HEAR FROM US TODAY. SO THE
TOPICS THAT WE HAVE, SORRY,
WE'RE HAVING A LITTLE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES HERE. THERE WE GO.
OKAY. I'M NOT SURE IF THE
POWERPOINT SLIDES ARE BEING
SHOWN TO THE AUDIENCE BECAUSE
ARE THEY OKAY. ALL RIGHT, SO I
WILL COVER THE SLIDES UP TO AND
INCLUDING WHERE WE TALK ABOUT AB
488. AND THEN I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO DAVID ELLER TO TALK
ABOUT THE REGISTRY. THE
MODERNIZATION THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW. AND THAT'S ONGOING,
AND ALSO TO TALK ABOUT THE
REGISTRY DATA. YOU DO THAT FOR
ME. YEAH THANK YOU, SO ANOTHER
OVERVIEW IS WHY DOES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE
SUPERVISORY AND ENFORCEMENT
POWERS OVER THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR? SO I WANT TO COVER THAT
JUST A LITTLE BIT FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE AUDIENCE THAT WE
HAVE HERE TODAY. AND THAT IS
BECAUSE THE CHARITABLE BENEFITS
OR CHARITABLE ASSETS ARE MEANT
FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE PEOPLE ARE THE
ULTIMATE BENEFICIARIES OF
CHARITABLE ASSETS. AND SO,
BECAUSE WE ARE INDEFINITE IN
NUMBER, AND THERE'S GENERALLY NO
ONE WHO'S GOING TO STEP UP TO
THE PLATE TO REPRESENT THE
INTERESTS OF THE PUBLIC. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS BEEN GIVEN
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO OVERSEE
CHARITABLE ENFORCEMENT POWERS TO
CHARITABLE OPERATIONS AND TO THE
ENFORCEMENT TO PROTECT FOR THE
INTEGRITY OF THE DONATIONS THAT
COME TO THE CHARITIES. IN THE
NEXT SLIDE HERE, YOU SEE THE
TYPES OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ENTITIES OVER WHICH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS JURISDICTION. IT'S
NOT JUST NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS, BUT ALSO FOR
PROFIT ENTITIES SUCH AS
FUNDRAISERS. AND WE ALSO MANY
TIMES GO INTO PROBATE COURTS TO
DEFEND AND TO PROTECT CHARITABLE
ASSETS THAT ARE GIVEN DURING THE
WILLS AND ESTATES PROCESS. AND
SO WE GO INTO COURT TO PROTECT
THEM, BECAUSE THOSE ARE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO HOW DOES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
OVERSEE HIS JURISDICTION OR
AUTHORITY OVER THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR? HE'S IT'S DONE THROUGH
THE REGISTRY OF CHARITIES AND
FUNDRAISERS. WE DO HAVE A NEW
NAME. IT'S NOT REGISTRY OF
CHARITABLE TRUSTS ANYMORE. AND
THE REASON WE CHANGED THE NAME
WAS IN RESPONSE TO COMMENTS FROM
THE PUBLIC THAT WE'RE NOT A
TRUST OR WHY DO WE HAVE TO
REGISTER? SO TO MAKE IT CLEAR,
WE CHANGED IT TO REGISTRY OF
CHARITIES AND FUNDRAISERS SO
THEY KNOW THE POPULATION THAT
NEEDS TO REGISTER AND REPORT TO
US. ANOTHER IMPORTANT PROGRAM
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE IS THE CHARITABLE TRUST
SECTION. THAT IS THE ENFORCEMENT
ARM. THAT'S THE INVESTIGATION
AND ENFORCEMENT ARM OF THE DOJ.
SO BACK TO THE REGISTRY, OF
WHICH DAVID ELLER IS THE HEAD.
WE HAVE MANY PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
REGISTRY, IT'S REGISTRATION,
RENEWALS OF REGISTRATION FOR
INSTANCE, THERE'S A GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT HANDLE DELINQUENCY
ISSUES. THERE WHEN CHARITIES
WANT TO DISSOLVE, THEY'RE
HELPING THEM TO DISSOLVE. OR IF
THEY WANT TO FUNDRAISE THROUGH
RAFFLES. WE HAVE PEOPLE
DEDICATED TO THE RAFFLES
PROGRAM. SO REGISTRATION AND
REPORTING THE RENEWALS IS NOT
THE ONLY PROGRAM WITHIN THE
REGISTRY. WE HAVE OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE JUST AS IMPORTANT FOR
WHICH THE REGISTRY STAFF
DEDICATE A LOT OF RESOURCES TO
HELP THE PUBLIC. OKAY, SO I THIS
IS THE NEXT FEW SLIDES I'LL
SHARE TO, ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
ABOUT, WELL, HOW DO REGISTERED
CHARITIES, MAINTAIN AND STAY
CURRENT IN THEIR REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS WITH THE STATE. SO
THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS THAT IS
TO REGISTER WITH US. OKAY. AND
HOW DO CHARITIES KNOW TO
REGISTER. WELL, THE FIRST,
NOTICE THAT THEY GET IS WHEN
THEY FORM THE NONPROFIT WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AFTER THEY
FORM IT, THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TELLS THEM, BY THE WAY, YOU NEED
TO REGISTER WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S REGISTRY SO THEY KNOW
TO COME TO US. AND SECONDLY, WE
DO A LOT OF OUTREACH, EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH. AND WE HAVE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE TO GIVE NOTICE TO THE
PUBLIC, TO CHARITIES THAT WANT
TO FORM, TO HOW TO HOW TO
OPERATE PROPERLY. SO FIRST STEP
IS TO REGISTER, AND ONCE YOU
SUBMIT THE DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED THAT I LIST HERE, WHICH
IS BASICALLY A REGISTRATION
FORM, PLUS YOU GIVE US YOUR
FOUNDING DOCUMENTS LIKE YOUR
ARTICLES OF INCORPORATION. YOU
YOU PAY THE INITIAL REGISTRATION
FEE OF $50, AND THEN YOU GIVE US
YOUR DOCUMENTS THAT ARE COMING
FROM THE IRS, SUCH AS YOUR,
CONFIRMATION OF YOUR TAX EXEMPT
STATUS. SO ONCE ALL OF THAT IS
RECEIVED AT THE REGISTRY AND THE
STAFF REVIEWS IT FOR COMPLIANCE,
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY WILL LOOK TO SEE IS
REGISTRATION IS REQUIRED WITHIN
30 DAYS OF RECEIPT OF PROPERTY.
SO IF THE ENTITY WHEN THEY'RE
REGISTERING AND SAID, WE GOT
PROPERTY IN 2020 AND THEY'RE
JUST REGISTERING IN 2024, WELL,
WE NEED TO CATCH AND HAVE THEM
FILE BACK FILINGS WILL REGISTER
THEM AND GIVE THEM A
REGISTRATION NUMBER. BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO GO AND COLLECT THE DATA,
LIKE THEIR FINANCIAL PICTURE AS
TO HOW THEY WERE FUNDRAISING AND
HOW THEY WERE SPENDING THOSE
FUNDS FOR THE PAST FOUR YEARS.
SO ONCE THEY'RE REGISTERED,
THEY'LL GET A CONFIRMATION
LETTER FROM THE REGISTRY. AND IN
THE LETTER THEY'LL SAY, THIS IS
YOUR REGISTRATION NUMBER. AND IN
THE LETTER, THEY ALSO TELL YOU
BY THE WAY, IN ADDITION TO
REGISTERING EVERY YEAR, YOU NEED
TO RENEW YOUR REGISTRATION AND
DOWN HERE BELOW I HAVE
INFORMATION ON THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC. WE HAVE WEBINARS ON HOW
TO REGISTER. WE HAVE FAQ
SECTIONS AND WE HAVE A VERY
DETAILED WEBPAGE ON HOW TO
REGISTER. SO THESE ARE ALL OF
OUR OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
EFFORTS BECAUSE WE WANT
CHARITIES TO SUCCEED. AND THE
MORE THEY KNOW ABOUT THE
REQUIREMENTS THEY'RE GOING TO
SUCCEED. OKAY. 15 MINUTES LEFT.
THANKS, ANTHONY. SO THIS IS JUST
A THE FIRST PAGE OF THE FORM
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO FILL OUT
TO REGISTER. AND THE REASON I
BROUGHT THAT UP, BECAUSE I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THERE WE ON THAT
FORM WERE ASKING FOR THE EMAIL
ADDRESS. WE'RE ASKING FOR YOU TO
CHECK. DO YOU WANT TO RECEIVE
EMAIL NOTIFICATIONS FROM THE
REGISTRY. AND WHEN THE ENTITY
CHECKS THAT BOX, WE CAN CONTACT
THEM WITH EMAIL. IT'S MUCH
FASTER. THIS. WE HAVE FOUND THAT
SOMETIMES WHEN WE SEND THEM
PAPER NOTICES, THEY'RE SOMEHOW
GETTING LOST. AND SO WE'RE
HOPING THAT WITH THIS EMAIL
ADDRESS WE CAN HAVE MULTIPLE
WAYS OF TRYING TO REACH THE
CHARITIES. IF WE NEED ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND TO SEND THEM
PRIOR NOTICES ABOUT WHEN THE
RENEWAL FILINGS ARE DUE. SO THIS
IS WHY I WANTED TO BRING THAT
OUT, SO THIS, PAGE IS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS THEN AFTER YOU INITIALLY
REGISTER? WELL, YOU HAVE TO
RENEW IT EVERY YEAR. AND IF YOU
DON'T RENEW IT, THIS IS WHEN YOU
COULD FALL INTO DELINQUENCY
STATUS. AND HOW DO YOU DO IT?
WELL, SO MY FIRST, COUPLE OF
BULLET POINTS TELL YOU HOW
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO RENEW AND YOU
BASICALLY FILE YOUR RENEWAL
FORM. YOU GIVE US YOUR 990 IRS
990 FORM THAT YOU FILED WITH THE
REGISTRY, AND YOU PAY A RENEWAL
FEE. AND THE RENEWAL FEE IS
BASED ON A SLIDING SCALE. SO,
FOR ENTITIES THAT HAVE REVENUE
BELOW $50,000, IT'S $25 TO RENEW
UP TO THOSE THAT HAVE $500
MILLION IN REVENUE. THEY PAY A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN THAT. SO,
SO THE FIRST BULLET POINT, FIRST
TWO ARE HOW DO YOU DO IT? AND
THE SECOND, THE NEXT BULLET
POINT IS WHEN DO YOU RENEW? WHEN
YOU RENEW, IT DEPENDS ON THE
CHARITIES OPERATING YEAR. ARE
YOU ON A CALENDAR YEAR OR ARE
YOU ON A FISCAL YEAR THAT STARTS
JULY 1ST AND GOES UNTIL JUNE
30TH? SO IF YOU ARE ON A
CALENDAR YEAR, YOU RENEW BY MAY
31ST. IF YOU'RE ON THE OTHER
FISCAL YEAR, BECAUSE MOST
CHARITIES FALL INTO EITHER ONE,
IF YOU'RE ON THE FISCAL YEAR,
THEN YOU RENEW BY NOVEMBER 15TH.
SO THOSE ARE THE TWO MAIN
DEADLINES. HOWEVER THE REGISTRY
WILL HONOR THE IRS EXTENSIONS OF
SIX MONTHS. SO IF, FOR INSTANCE,
I'M GIVING YOU AN EXAMPLE, IF A
CHARITY IS ON A CALENDAR
REGISTRATION YEAR, THEIR FILINGS
WERE THE RENEWAL FILINGS ARE DUE
ON MAY 15TH, BUT THEY GET AN IRS
EXTENSION OR WE ACTUALLY ASSUME
THEY GOT IT. BECAUSE IF NOTHING
CAME IN FOR THE MAY 15TH FILING,
WE'RE GOING TO ASSUME THEY GOT
AN EXTENSION FROM THE IRS. IT
TAKES THEM TO MAY 15TH. ON
NOVEMBER 15TH. BY THE TIME THE
STAFF GOES THROUGH 20,000 PLUS
PIECES OF MAIL THAT CAME IN TO
PROCESS THE NOVEMBER 15TH
DEADLINE, IT TAKES US TO THE
NEXT YEAR BY WHICH WE KIND OF
HAVE A NOTICE AS TO WHICH
POPULATION OF CHARITIES NEVER
FILED ANYTHING FOR THEIR MAY
15TH DEADLINE, AND IT'S AT THAT
POINT, WHICH IS THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR, LIKE FEBRUARY OR
MARCH, THAT WE START ISSUING
DELINQUENCY NOTICES. THESE
DELINQUENCY NOTICES PROVIDE FOR
30 DAYS TO FIX THE DELINQUENCY
STATUS. WE ISSUED TWO OF THOSE
LETTERS. SO THEN COMBINED THEY
GIVE YOU 60 MORE DAYS TO FILE
THE RENEWAL FILINGS. BY THE TIME
ALL THAT PERIOD IS DONE WITH,
YOU'RE ALMOST TIME TO FILE
ANOTHER ONE. SO IT THE SIMPLE
ANSWER THE MINUTE. OH I'M SORRY,
WHAT. ONE MORE MINUTE. YOU'RE AT
NINE MINUTES. OH OKAY. SO WE
DON'T HAVE AN EQUAL DIVISION OF
THE SLIDES. WE DID DIVIDE THEM
EQUALLY. YES. SO, THE ANSWER IS
WHEN DO THEY TURN DELINQUENT IF
THEY DON'T REGISTER ON TIME OR
RENEW REGISTRATION ON TIME
ALMOST A YEAR AFTER IT WAS DUE,
THE FILINGS WERE DUE. OKAY HE'S
RUSHING ME. ALL RIGHT. SO, LET'S
GO TO THE INCOMPLETE. SO I WANT
TO SKIP OVER BECAUSE I'M JUST
SHOWING YOU THE FORMS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO RENEW. AND ALSO
WE'RE COLLECTING EMAIL ADDRESSES
AGAIN. WE'RE ALSO ASKING FOR DO
YOU HAVE A NEW ADDRESS? DO YOU
CHECK THE BOX BECAUSE WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
CHARITIES OKAY. SO WE ARE GOING
TO INCOMPLETE REGISTRATION NOW.
SO NOW THIS HAPPENS WITH BOTH
ENTITIES THAT ARE IN GOOD
STANDING. THAT'S CREATING THEIR
REGISTRATION. AND THOSE THAT ARE
IN DELINQUENCY STATUS. SO
CHARITIES THAT ARE CURRENT AND
CURRENT, THEY'RE THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY DELINQUENT FILINGS. THEY
SUBMIT THEIR RENEWAL. BUT THEY
FORGOT TO SUBMIT SOMETHING OR
THEY DIDN'T SIGN IT, OR THERE'S
NO CHECK OR THEY DIDN'T ANSWER
ONE OF THE NINE QUESTIONS ON THE
RENEWAL FORM. THEN THEIR STATUS
STAYS CURRENT, INCOMPLETE
REPORTING. IT DOES NOT CHANGE TO
DELINQUENCY. WHEN THEY GET THAT
STATUS, THE STAFF IS WORKING
WITH THEM, SENDING THEM NOTICES.
THIS IS WHY IT'S INCOMPLETE. YOU
MUST SUBMIT THIS DOCUMENT AND WE
GIVE THEM A CONTACT INFORMATION.
IN ADDITION, STAFF PUTS NOTES
INTO THE PUBLIC DATABASE THAT
CHARITIES COULD SEE IN THE
PUBLIC Tê THEY HAVE NOTES IN
THEIR INCOMPLETE SUBMISSION,
MISSING FORM 990. FOR INSTANCE.
OKAY, SO INCOMPLETE SUBMISSION
COULD ALSO BE COMING IN FROM A
DELINQUENT CHARITY WHEN A
DELINQUENT CHARITY IS TRYING TO
CURE THEIR DELINQUENCY, THEY ARE
SENDING DOCUMENTS IN TO CURE IT,
BUT THEY FORGET SOMETHING OR
THERE MORE THAN ONE YEAR
DELINQUENT. SO THEY SAY THEY'RE
LIKE THREE YEARS DELINQUENT.
THEY SEND IN PAPERWORK FOR TWO
YEARS AND FORGOT THE THIRD YEAR.
THEIR STATUS HAS NOT CHANGED
FROM DELINQUENT TO INCOMPLETE
SUBMISSION. IT STATES DELINQUENT
UNTIL THEY FIX THE DELINQUENCY
BECAUSE THEY WERE ALREADY IN THE
DELINQUENCY DELINQUENT STATUS.
SO IN THE INCOMPLETE AGAIN, I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE, WHEN YOU GET
AN INCOMPLETE NOTICE, IT GIVES
YOU A CONTACT INFORMATION ON HOW
TO REACH US. IT TELLS YOU WHAT'S
MISSING, AND WE PUT NOTES INTO
THE PUBLIC DATABASE. THE CHARITY
CAN SEE. IN CASE YOU MISSED OUR
NOTICE, IN CASE YOU DIDN'T GET
THAT LETTER FROM US, YOU CAN
LOOK IT UP. YOU CAN SEE WHAT WAS
MISSING. I JUST WANT TO NOTE.
SORRY, I JUST WANT TO NOTE WE'RE
OVER TIME. BUT YOU SAID YOU'RE
SHARING TIME WITH SOMEONE. YES,
I'M SHARING TIME. SO THEN I'LL
JUST STOP YOU AT 20 MINUTES,
OKAY? YES. AND SO THIS IS THE I
WANT TO SHOW YOU. THIS IS WHAT
THE REGISTRY SEARCH PAGE LOOKS
LIKE. SO THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND THE CHARITY COULD
LOOK UP THEIR STATUS. THEY CAN
SEE BY GOING HERE. OKAY, THIS IS
THE NEXT PAGE OF WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE. YOU CAN SEE ALL THE
FILINGS THAT YOU SUBMITTED TO
THE REGISTRY. YOU CAN CLICK ON
IT. YOU CAN SEE THE 990 FORM.
YOU CAN SEE THE ART FORM. AND
YOU CAN SEE THE NOTE THE STAFF
PUT IN LIKE HERE. NOTE HERE SAYS
SO TINY. OKAY I THINK IT SAYS
RESUBMISSION LIKE ACCEPTED
CORRECTION ACCEPTED. YEAH.
CORRECTION THANK YOU. CORRECTION
ACCEPTED. IT SAYS THERE'S A NOTE
SO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO CHECK
BACK WITH THE REGISTRY. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO SAY HEY DID YOU
ACCEPT MY RENEWED RESUBMISSION.
WE TOLD YOU IT'S BEEN ACCEPTED.
OKAY THANK ME OKAY I'M PICKING
UP THE PACE OKAY. SO I WANT TO
GO INTO AB 488 AND BEFORE I HAND
IT OVER TO DAVID. SO AB 488 IS
ONE OF THE NEW TYPE OF
FUNDRAISING PROFESSIONALS THAT
ARE IN CALIFORNIA, OKAY? THEY
FUNDRAISE ON PLATFORMS ON BEHALF
OF CHARITIES. SO ÁP SO SOME OF
THE DETAILS ARE HERE. WHEN DID
IT BECOME LAW? WHERE IS IT IN
THE GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION,
WHEN DID THE REGULATIONS THAT
ARE IMPLEMENTING THESE SECTIONS
GO INTO, GO INTO EFFECT, AND
WHEN DID REGISTRATION START. SO
REGISTRATION STARTED ON JUNE
12TH. WE HAVE ALMOST 60
ENTITIES, PLATFORMS THAT HAVE
SUBMITTED THEIR REGISTRATION
DOCUMENTS AND THEY HAVE UNTIL
OCTOBER 12TH TO ACTUALLY
REGISTER AND SO THESE ARE THE
EARLY FILERS THAT ARE GETTING
THEIR PAPERWORK IN ON TIME. AND
THIS HAS MORE INFORMATION ABOUT,
WHAT FORMS ARE REQUIRED. AND
EVERYTHING ABOUT PLATFORMS IS
DONE ELECTRONICALLY. AND THIS IS
ONE OF THE MODERNIZATION PROJECT
THAT DAVE WILL DISCUSS. WE BUILT
A SYSTEM SO THAT NOW PLATFORMS
CAN REGISTER AND FILE ALL THEIR
REPORTS ELECTRONICALLY, AND WE
ARE MOVING TOWARDS ALL CHARITIES
BEING ABLE TO DO THAT IN SIX
MINUTES. OKAY. THANK YOU. I WILL
NOW TURN IT OVER TO DAVID ELLER.
THANK YOU, ELIZABETH, AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE WHAT WE'RE UP TO. SO AS
ELIZABETH MENTIONED, THERE'S
REALLY THREE MAIN, THEMES OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING, WHAT OUR GOALS
ARE, AND REALLY THE DIRECTION OF
THE DEPARTMENT. ONE IS
COMMUNICATION, BOTH PASSIVE AND
ACTIVE AS, AS ELIZABETH
MENTIONED, SOME OF THE PASSIVE
COMMUNICATIONS ARE WITH WEBSITE
ENHANCEMENT WEBINARS. C¯ FAQ
CONTENT, ETC. AND THEN WITH
DIRECT COMMUNICATIONS, EITHER
THROUGH NOTIFICATIONS OR THROUGH
REMINDERS AND WE'RE HOPING TO
LEVERAGE MORE WITH EMAIL IN
ADDITION TO JUST MORE
TRADITIONAL LETTERS AND SO
FORTH. THE SECOND IS JUST
COMPLIANCE, MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE MANAGING WHAT THE
CHARITIES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
SUBMITTING AND PROVIDING TO US
AND TO THE PUBLIC AND BEING
CONSISTENT WITH THAT AS FAR AS
STATUS MAINTENANCE AND TAKING
ANY ACTIONS THAT ARE REQUIRED
DUE TO NON COMPLIANCE. AND THE
THIRD REALLY AND I'M SURE THIS
IS WHAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN IS
PROCESS ENHANCEMENTS. WHAT ARE
WE DOING TO IMPROVE OUR
WORKFLOW. AND IMPROVE THE
TIMELINESS OF WHAT WE DO MAKE
SUBMISSION REQUIREMENTS MORE
EASY TO CONVEY TO US FROM THE
PUBLIC, AND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT I WILL BE
TOUCHING ON IN BRIEF HERE. WHAT
WE HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU FOR THE
SLIDE JUST IDENTIFIES OUR KEY
GOALS, THEY'RE VERY STREAMLINED
AND REALLY REINFORCE WHAT I'VE
JUST MENTIONED. FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS TO COMPLETE THE
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PROJECT,
AND I'LL BE GOING OVER THAT IN A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL IN THE
FOLLOWING SLIDE. WE'VE BROKEN
THAT UP INTO TWO PHASES. AND
AGAIN, I WILL GO OVER THAT IN
MORE DETAIL JUST IN A SECOND.
SECONDLY, TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
CURRENT TO DELINQUENT STATUS
RATIOS. AND THAT'S REALLY THE
HEART OF OUR COMPLIANCE, MAKING
SURE THAT WE MAXIMIZE THE
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR CHARITIES
THAT THEY'RE REGISTERED AND
CURRENT. AND THAT WE'RE REALLY,
ABLE TO HAVE MORE TIME TO FOCUS
ON ORGANIZATIONS. THE REMAINDER,
WHICH ARE THE DELINQUENT
ORGANIZATIONS, THE NON
PERFORMING ORGANIZATIONS, THIRD
IS TO RESTORE THE IMPORT OF DATA
THAT WE RECEIVE FROM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND TO ALSO
GET THE ENHANCED EMAIL
INFORMATION AS WELL. OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE VERY MUCH DATA DRIVEN. AND
SO THE MORE GOOD DATA WE CAN GET
IN A TIMELY MANNER, THE MORE,
PROACTIVE WE CAN BE WITH OUR
COMMUNICATIONS AS FAR AS
REGISTRATION, AND ALSO WITH THE
REMINDERS AS WELL, ONCE WE HAVE
THAT EMAIL ADDRESS. FOURTH IS TO
LEVERAGE AND APPLY ENHANCED
AUTOMATION AND DATA TO IMPROVE
ANALYTICS AND COMPLIANCE. SO
AGAIN, RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ABOUT
107 REGISTERED 107,000
REGISTERED CHARITIES, WE HAVE
PROBABLY MORE MORE THAN THAT
THAT ARE UNREGISTERED AND SO
IT'S A VERY LARGE POPULATION.
AND WE REALLY WANT TO UNDERSTAND
THE ENTIRE POPULATION. AND
SEGMENT IT APPROPRIATELY TO
REALLY TAKE TO HAVE STRATEGIES
THAT ARE EFFECTIVE FOR EACH
POPULATION. AND SO BY GETTING
THE DATA, ANALYZE IT,
UNDERSTANDING IT, WE CAN DEVELOP
STRATEGIES AGAINST THOSE
POPULATIONS. AND FINALLY, TO
LEVERAGE AUTOMATION TO IMPROVE
SERVICE DELIVERY AND
COMMUNICATION WITH THE PUBLIC.
SO WE'RE HEARING A LOT I'M SURE
WE'LL HEAR A LOT OF IT THROUGH
TODAY. AND WE'VE HEARD IT
CONTINUALLY. EVERY DAY, THAT
COMMUNICATION ABOUT WHAT OUR
REQUIREMENTS ARE, WHAT OUR
PROCESS IS, WHAT WE EXPECT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC
AND FOR THE CHARITIES TO BE ABLE
TO ACT AND TO COMPLY. SO WE
UNDERSTAND OUR RESPONSIBILITY,
AND WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB TO IMPROVE SERVICE
DELIVERY AND COMMUNICATION IN
SUPPORT OF THAT. OKAY OKAY. SO
THIS NEXT SLIDE GOES INTO A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL RELATIVE TO
OUR AUTOMATION PROJECT OR WHAT
WE CALL BUSINESS MODERNIZATION.
AND IN A NUTSHELL, THE GOAL IS
TO UPGRADE THE REGISTRY'S
TECHNICAL PLATFORM TO IMPROVE
EFFICIENCY, SERVICE AND DELIVERY
STANDARDS, ENHANCED DATA
MANAGEMENT FOR PURPOSES OF
ADVANCED ANALYTICS, QUALITY
CONTROL, RETENTION, COMPLIANCE,
AND TO INTEGRATE AND BROADEN
PAYMENT PROCESSING WITH
ELECTRONIC TRANSACTION
SUBMISSIONS. THAT'S BOTH FOR
FORMS, FEES AND DATA. ONE OTHER
THING I WANTED TO BRING UP, I
DID TELL YOU THAT WE HAVE ABOUT
107 REGISTERED, 107,000
REGISTERED CHARITIES. WE HAVE IN
OUR DATABASE, ABOUT 4 MILLION,
PDF, ARTIFACTS, PROBABLY ABOUT,
ABOUT 300, 3.5 MILLION OF THOSE
ARE PUBLIC AND SO, AS ELIZABETH
SHOWED YOU THROUGH THE INQUIRY
TOOL, THE VERIFICATION TOOL
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC, ALL OF
THOSE 3.5 MILLION RECORDS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR INSPECTION BY THE
PUBLIC. AND PART OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE ARE AVAILABLE AGAIN,
SO THAT THE PUBLIC CAN MAKE GOOD
GIVING DECISIONS AND CAN REALLY
LOOK AT FIRSTHAND WHAT THE
CHARITIES ARE REPORTING AND WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WITH, CHARITABLE
FUNDS, THE FOLLOWING ELEMENTS
DEFINE THE KEY COMPONENTS OF THE
AUTOMATION PROJECT ONE. WE WANT
SUBMISSION WORKFLOWS FOR
PLATFORM FUNDRAISING. THAT'S
GONE INTO PLACE, THAT WAS
EFFECTIVE IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT EFFORT,
PLATFORM FUND APPLICATION FORMS
ARE NOW SUBMITTED ONLINE WITH
ONLINE PAYMENTS, WHICH IS GREAT
WITH CHARITIES RIGHT NOW, YOU
CAN ONLY DO RENEWAL FEE
SUBMISSION ONLINE. YOU CAN'T DO
REGISTRATION, THE SECOND GOAL IS
PAYMENT EXPANSION. SO WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE ALL PAYMENT
TYPES, BE ABLE TO BE SUBMITTED
ONLINE ALONG WITH THE
CORRESPONDING FORMS. AND AGAIN,
LIKE I MENTIONED RIGHT NOW FOR
CHARITIES, RENEWALS IS THE ONLY
AVENUE FOR ONLINE PAYMENT. WE
WANT TO BROADEN THAT FOR
REGISTRATION FOR RAFEAL, FOR
PROFESSIONAL FUND FUNDRAISING,
ALL FEE TYPES, NEXT WE WANT
AUTOMATION AND WORKFLOW AND
NOTIFICATIONS. SO WE WANT THE
ABILITY TO HAVE TRIGGER
SCENARIOS THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
REMIND YOU, HEY, YOUR RENEWAL
FORMS ARE DUE NEXT MONTH, OR
HEY, YOU'RE YOU'RE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE AND THIS IS YOUR
FIRST OR YOUR SECOND NOTICE. SO
THESE ARE PROACTIVE
COMMUNICATION MEASURES THAT WE'D
LIKE TO PUT INTO PLACE. AND
HOPEFULLY UTILIZING, YOU KNOW,
ELECTRONIC NOTIFICATIONS EMAIL,
SO THAT THEY CAN BE MORE TIMELY
AND HOPEFULLY, MORE NOTICEABLE.
BECAUSE WE DO KNOW THAT EMAIL
ADDRESSES SEEM TO HAVE GREATER
LONGEVITY THAN, LET'S SAY, A TOS,
ADDRESS, BECAUSE THAT MAY BE
TIED TO A TREASURER WHO IS A
VOLUNTEER WHOSE CHILD IS NOW
MOVED ON TO ANOTHER SCHOOL. AND
SO, BOOM, THEY HAVE TO RESET.
THEY HAVE A NEW ADDRESS, WHEREAS
AN EMAIL ADDRESS, HOPEFULLY, IF
IT'S TIED TO THE ORGANIZATION,
WILL REMAIN ONGOING. THAT'S OUR
HOPE, NEXT IS TO REPLACE OUR
DATABASE SOFTWARE. SO AS I
MENTIONED AGAIN, WE'VE GOT ABOUT
4 MILLION RECORDS, WE NEED TO
AUTOMATE THAT SO THAT WE CAN
REALLY DO, ANALYSIS APPROACH
MAINTENANCE AND, BE ABLE TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO PRA REQUESTS OR
I'M JUST GOING TO ASK YOU TO
WRAP UP. YOU'RE JUST OVER.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY OKAY, SO OUR
PHASE ONE IS IN, PHASE TWO IS
TARGETED FOR JULY OF NEXT YEAR.
OKAY. JUST THE NEXT SLIDE. I
WON'T GO OVER THOSE THINGS.
THERE'S JUST SOME STATISTICS
RELATIVE TO THE, SOME OF THE
NOTICES WE SENT OUT
REGISTRATIONS AND RENEWALS. SO
IN SUMMARY, CHARITIES HAVE A
LONG STANDING RESPONSIBILITY TO
REGISTER AND REMAIN IN GOOD
STANDING TO OPERATE AND RECEIVE
DONATIONS. SO THAT'S REALLY A
CORE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
CHARITIES AND FOR US TO ENSURE
THAT IS HAPPENING THROUGH
COMPLIANCE. ACTIVITIES.
SECONDLY, DOJ PLACES A STRONG
EMPHASIS AND DEVOTES RESOURCES
TO PREVENT CHARITIES FROM
BECOMING DELINQUENT IN THE FIRST
PLACE. WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
TAKE THE UPSTREAM APPROACH WITH
PROACTIVE COMMUNICATIONS AND
TRYING TO AVOID THE SITUATION
WHERE THEY'RE HAVING TO GET OUT
OF THE DELINQUENCY HOLE. THAT'S
THAT'S OUR GOAL, AND AGAIN, WITH
RESPECT TO CLEARING
DELINQUENCIES, RESOLVING A
DELINQUENCY INVOLVES A LEGAL
COMPLIANCE REVIEW. IT'S USUALLY
NOT AS SIMPLE AS JUST ACCEPTING
A FEE THAT HASN'T BEEN PAID,
THERE'S A LOT OF ATTENTION TO
MAKING SURE THAT INFORMATION IS
CORRECT, AND IT MAKES SENSE AND
THAT IT REALLY IS CONSISTENT
WITH REPORTING RESPONSIBILITIES
IN THE LAW. AND FINALLY, TO
PRIORITIZE OUR RESOURCES TO
ENSURE FAIRNESS TO ALL. AND IN
GENERAL, WE PROCESS FILINGS IN
THE ORDER THAT THEY'RE RECEIVED.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE TIME AND
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
INFORMATION. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WE WILL MOVE TO OUR NEXT
PANELIST, JOHN JONES FROM COCO
KIDS. HI GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATOR
LAMONT AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
HEART AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS JOHN JONES, AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COCO KIDS,
A CHILD CARE RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL AGENCY. AND WE ALSO DO
AN ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. WE
PROVIDE ACCESS TO CHILD CARE FOR
OVER 5000 CHILDREN AND MAKE
PAYMENTS FOR THOSE SERVICES ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, I AM HONORED TO
SHARE OUR EXPERIENCE WITH THE
REGISTRY OF CHARITABLE TRUSTS.
FILLING THE NEW NAME FOR THEIR.
IT IS NOT MY INTENT TO
ILLUSTRATE A BROKEN SYSTEM OF
TRANSPARENCY IN A GOVERNMENT
OFFICE. MY EXAMPLE IS ONE WHERE
IMPROVED COMMUNICATION WILL
RESULT IN A BENEFIT TO SERVICE
DELIVERY FOR CALIFORNIA CITIZENS.
ACCORDING TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE, CHARITIES
REPRESENT AN IMPORTANT ECONOMIC
SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA AND
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. IN
JANUARY 2021, THERE WERE OVER
118,000 CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS
REGISTERED WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S REGISTRY OF CHARITABLE
TRUSTS. AS OF JUNE 2019, THESE
REGISTERED CHARITIES REPORTED
TOTAL REVENUES OF OVER 293
BILLION AND TOTAL ASSETS OF OVER
854 BILLION. AS A CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATION FOR OVER 45 YEARS,
COCO KIDS HAS MAINTAINED OUR 500
1C3 STATUS, CONDUCTED ANNUAL
FINANCIAL AUDITS, AND FILE OUR
IRS 990 TAX FORM. ALL DOCUMENTS
ARE AVAILABLE TO THE STATE,
COUNTY AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
FOUNDATIONS, DONORS AND THE
PUBLIC. ON OCTOBER 22ND, 2022,
WE WERE NOTIFIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT OUR STATUS WITH THE
REGISTRY OF CHARITABLE TRUSTS
WAS MARKED DELINQUENT. AS A
RESULT, THEY WOULD NOT PAY THE
NEXT INSTALLMENT OF FUNDS FOR
CHILD CARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CONTRACT YEAR. THIS WOULD RESULT
IN CHILD CARE PROVIDERS NOT
BEING PAID FOR SERVICES. WE
QUICKLY SET OUT TO CORRECT THE
SITUATION GOING TO THE REGISTRY
WEBSITE. WE FOUND IT CHALLENGING
TO IDENTIFY THE MISSING
DOCUMENTS AS WELL AS FIND A
CONTACT TO ASSIST US IN
CORRECTING THE PROBLEM. WE
FINALLY DID RECEIVE AN EMAIL
WITHOUT A CONTACT NAME FROM THE
REGISTRY OFFICE IDENTIFYING THE
MISSING DOCUMENTS. WE WERE
MISSING OUR 990 TAX FORM FROM
2018 AND 2021, AND WITH THE
RENEWAL FORMS FROM 2018 AND
2019, ALL DOCUMENTS AND FEES
WERE SUBMITTED ON NOVEMBER 17TH.
ON DECEMBER FIRST, WE WERE
NOTIFIED THAT ALL FORMS WERE
RECEIVED, BUT A RENEWAL FORM
CREATED IN 2022 WAS NEEDED FOR
2018 AND 2019. THESE DOCUMENTS
WERE SUBMITTED ON DECEMBER 15TH,
ALONG WITH ANOTHER CHECK TO
COVER ANY FILING FEES. WE WERE
ALSO APPROACHED. WE WERE ALSO
APPROACHING OUR JANUARY 2023
DEADLINE TO FILE FOR CONTINUED
FUNDING APPLICATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THEY
WILL NOT ACCEPT A CONTINUED
APPLICATION. IF YOU HAVE A
DELINQUENT STATUS WITH THE
REGISTRY, AND WE WERE ALSO
WAITING FOR OUR NEXT SCHEDULED
CONTRACT PAYMENT. WE WAITED
PATIENTLY FOR A CHANGE IN OUR
STATUS ONLINE, SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO BUSINESS. OUR
CALLS AND EMAILS REGARDING OUR
STATUS WERE NOT RETURNED. ON
JANUARY 12TH, 2023, I DROVE TO
SACRAMENTO TO VISIT THE DOJ
OFFICE AND TO SPEAK WITH ANYONE
WHO COULD HELP RESOLVE THE
ISSUE. AT THAT TIME, THE
BUILDING WAS CLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC AND I WAS NOT PERMITTED
TO GO UPSTAIRS TO THE REGISTRY
OF CHARITABLE TRUSTS. BUT A
SECURITY GUARD WAS WILLING TO GO
UPSTAIRS AND ASK FOR SOMEONE TO
COME DOWN AND TALK WITH ME IN
THE LOBBY. AFTER ABOUT 15
MINUTES, A STAFF MEMBER CAME
DOWN. I EXPLAINED MY SITUATION.
HE WENT BACK UPSTAIRS AND WAS
ABLE TO FIND THE DOCUMENTS AND
PAYMENT. WE SENT OUR STATUS WAS
CHANGED THAT DAY AND WE RECEIVED
OUR NEXT PAYMENT AND SUBMITTED
FOR A CONTINUED APPLICATION FOR
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR. I FOUND
OUT LATER THAT MANY OF MY
PARTNER NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
WERE IN A SIMILAR SITUATION,
WITH NO IMMEDIATE RESPONSE FROM
THE OFFICE FOR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONTINUE TO
PARTNER AND COLLABORATE WITH THE
GOVERNMENT, THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
IMPORTANT LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY
AND AN ELEVATED LEVEL OF
COMMUNICATION. OUR SITUATION
COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED IF WE
HAD HAD SOMEONE TO SPEAK WITH
DIRECTLY TO RESOLVE THE
SITUATION. FOR US, THE DELIVERY
OF SERVICES IS TIME SENSITIVE.
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS CANNOT BE
LEFT WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO PAY
THEIR BILLS, PURCHASE FOOD AND
SUPPLIES SO THEY COULD CARE FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE. I DO
BELIEVE IN THE REGISTRY OF
CHARITABLE TRUSTS RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC FROM
FRAUDULENT, NONPROFIT AND
DECEPTIVE ONLINE FUNDRAISING.
THOSE WHO SEEK TO MISLEAD THE
PUBLIC DO NOT REGISTER WITH THE
TRUST. ORGANIZATIONS LISTED WITH
THE REGISTRY CAN IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY. IF AN IMPROVED
METHOD OF COMMUNICATIONS WERE IN
PLACE. THE REGISTRY OF
CHARITABLE TRUSTS COULD ALSO
BENEFIT FROM INCREASED
RESOURCES. IT IS IN THE PUBLIC'S
BEST INTEREST THAT THE 118,000
REGISTERED ORGANIZATIONS
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SERVICES
WITHOUT INTERRUPTIONS, AS
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
THAT'S WHAT I WROTE OUT. I JUST
WANTED TO ADD IN RESPONSE TO I
KNOW THEY'VE MADE SOME GAINS, SO
THERE'S BEEN A COUPLE OF YEARS,
SO I APPLAUD THOSE GAINS BEING
MADE. BUT I THINK FOR US, WHAT
WAS REALLY CRITICAL IS THE
COMMUNICATION TO OTHER
GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE
WE WEREN'T NOTIFIED BY THE
TRUST, WE WERE NOTIFIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES,
AND THEY HAD THEIR RULES THAT
THEY COULDN'T MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT THESE RULES BEING
SETTLED. SO WHAT WAS MISSING IS
NOT JUST THE COMMUNICATION TO
NONPROFITS. IT'S THE
COMMUNICATION WITHIN GOVERNMENT
DEPARTMENTS SO THAT WE CONTINUE
TO DO THESE SERVICES WITHOUT
INTERRUPTION, BECAUSE THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE REALLY FEAR IS
THE IMPACT IT WILL HAVE TO ON
OUR COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND ON THAT NOTE,
WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS. BUT,
COLLEAGUES, I'M WONDERING IF
IT'S JUST OKAY SINCE I FEEL LIKE,
MR. JONES COMMENTS RAISED
INITIAL QUESTIONS. IF YOU COULD
JUST RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT MR. JONES
EXPERIENCED AND WHAT THE
COMMUNICATION IS WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS. BUT ALSO, YOU KNOW,
HOW DO WE NAVIGATE A SITUATION
WHERE MR. JONES HIMSELF HAD TO
PHYSICALLY COME TO GET AN
ANSWER? I'M JUST WONDERING IF
YOU CAN RESPOND AND GIVE US
FEEDBACK AND THEN IF IT'S OKAY
WITH YOU ALL, THEN WE'LL KICK IT
OFF FOR QUESTIONS. I JUST FEEL
LIKE MR. JONES POSED A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS THAT, ARE YOU KNOW,
MERIT AN ANSWER. I THINK WITHOUT
HAVING THE BENEFIT OF HAVING
GONE THROUGH HIS REGISTRATION
FILINGS FOR ISSUES RELATED TO
RENEWALS, I'LL JUST BRIEFLY
TOUCH UPON, I WANT TO I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE APPROACH THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN TO UPSTREAM AND
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
RENEWAL PROCESS. THIS IS SO THAT
WE COULD IT COULD BE
PREVENTATIVE SO THAT WE DON'T
WANT CHARITIES TO FALL INTO
DELINQUENCY BECAUSE WE I
DISCUSSED THAT CHARITIES DON'T
FALL INTO DELINQUENCY UNLESS
UNTIL ALMOST A YEAR AFTER THE
DELINQUENT THE DOCUMENT WAS DUE.
SO IT SOUNDED LIKE TO ME THE
ENTITY WAS MORE THAN ONE YEAR
DELINQUENT. SO I THINK THERE
SHOULD BE. I ENCOURAGE A PROCESS
OF MAYBE HAVING A BINDER THAT
COULD BE PASSED, THAT COULD BE
MAYBE PRESENT AND TAKEN TO EVERY
BOARD MEETING TO TALK ABOUT WHEN
ARE SOME OF THESE DUE DATES, FOR
THE DOJ, FOR THE SSOS, FOR THE
IRS AND FTP. SO I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD BE A VERY GOOD
GOVERNANCE PRACTICE FOR THE
CHARITY. BUT SECONDLY, I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT, REVIEW WHEN YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE YEARS OF DELINQUENCY,
REVIEW ISN'T JUST, OH, LET'S
CHECK THE BOX THIS CAME IN THAT
CAME IN, THAT CAME IN. DOJ IS A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. THE
REVIEW HAS TO BE DONE FOR LEGAL
COMPLIANCE ISSUES. THERE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT GET ANSWERED FOR
INSTANCE, I WANT TO JUST POINT
OUT THAT IF YOU HAVE REVENUE
NOTED ON THE R FORM, THE RR F
RENEWAL FORM IS ONE NUMBER. BUT
WHAT WE LOOK AT, THE IRS 990,
IT'S A DIFFERENT NUMBER OR THE
EXPENSES. DON'T LIGHT UP. THAT
IS A CONCERN TO US BECAUSE THEY
SHOULD BE LINING UP, LINING UP.
AND IF THEY DON'T LINE UP, YOU
SHOULD HAVE AN EXPLANATION TO US
AS TO WHY. OR MAYBE THE OUR FORM
WAS NOT SIGNED BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO SIGN IT UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY, AND YOU HAVE TO ATTEST
THAT YOU HAVE AUTHORITY TO
SUBMIT THE DOCUMENT ON BEHALF OF
THE CHARITY AND THE SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
ARE CALLING FOR SOME NARRATIVE
RESPONSES. FOR INSTANCE, WE
ASKED, WAS THERE EMBEZZLEMENT
DURING THE REPORTING PERIOD? IF
YOU CHECK THAT, YES, WE WANT AN
ANSWER. WE WANT YOU TO EXPLAIN.
DID YOU HAVE ANY LOANS GIVEN TO
AN ENTITY FROM FROM THE CHARITY
TO A DIRECTOR? WE WANT AN
ANSWER. SO THESE ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE REVIEWING FOR
COMPLIANCE. IT'S NOT JUST CHECK
THE BOX. OUR ANALYSTS ARE DOING
A LOT MORE THAN JUST CHECKING
THE BOX. SO IN ADDITION TO LEGAL
COMPLIANCE, I DON'T WANT
CHARITIES TO GET THERE. WE'VE
MADE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
THEM. WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME
TRYING TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
ABOUT IT. OKAY. AND IN ADDITION
TO THAT, SO THANK YOU FOR COMING
UP. I MEAN, DURING COVID, YOU
CAME TO THE REGISTRY AND I'M
GLAD THAT WE WERE ABLE TO HELP
YOU, BUT SO WE WANTED TO. SO
WHEN WE IDENTIFY, I WANT TO
TEACH THEM HOW TO GO TO THAT
THAT SEARCH TOOL. I WANT
CHARITIES TO KNOW ABOUT IT. I
WANT THEM TO SEE WHAT NOTES WE
PUT IN THERE ABOUT WHAT'S
MISSING. AND WE DO PROVIDE
CONTACT INFORMATION AND THERE IS
EMAILS BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
THE ENTITY AND THE REGISTRY
STAFF TO GET THE ISSUES
RESOLVED, BUT IT JUST TAKES
LONGER. IF IT'S MORE THAN ONE
YEAR OF DELINQUENCY. AND SO
THERE'S AND I ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT DURING WHAT FILING
PERIOD WAS THIS BROUGHT UP?
BECAUSE IT COULD TAKE LONGER IF
FOR INSTANCE, DID THIS ISSUE
COME UP IN MAY OR NOVEMBER?
SOMETIMES WE GET CHARITIES
SAYING, I SUBMITTED THE
DOCUMENTS, YOU KNOW, A FEW DAYS
AGO, I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING,
IT'S A RUSH BECAUSE WE HAVE A
GRANT PENDING. WE TRY NOT TO
HAVE CHARITIES LOSE THEIR GRANT.
WHAT DO WE HAVE TO DO? WE ARE
GOING THROUGH THOSE 20 PIECES OF
20 000 PIECES OF DOCUMENTS,
TRYING TO CATEGORIZE IT. BY
WHICH WEEK DID IT COME IN? AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE COULD HELP
THEM, WE'RE SEARCHING THROUGH
THOSE DOCUMENTS BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT'S NOT AUTOMATED, ALTHOUGH
WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE TOWARDS
THAT. WE ARE PHYSICALLY GOING
THROUGH EACH DOCUMENT TO TRY TO
LOCATE IT SO THAT WE COULD GIVE
IT TO AN ANALYST TO REVIEW IT
FOR COMPLIANCE ISSUES. RIGHT. SO
IF YOU COULD PICTURE 20,000 OR
22,000 PIECES OF HARD MAIL
COMING IN, IT GETS OPENED.
CHECKS ARE ATTACHED TO THE
FILING. THEN ONCE THE CHECKS ARE
ACCOUNTED FOR, WE HAVE TO CHECK
OUT ALL THE STAPLERS. WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
CONFIDENTIAL DOCUMENT THEY
WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO GIVE US IN
THERE. THEN THEY'RE SCANNED,
THEN THEY'RE UPLOADED AND
THEY'RE SEPARATED INTO DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS. THEN ANALYSTS ARE
LOOKING AT IT FOR COMPLIANCE
REVIEW. SO THIS IS THE PROCESS
THAT GOES THROUGH. AND IT TAKES
THAT MUCH LONGER. IF YOU'RE
SUBMITTING SOMETHING DURING MAY
AND NOVEMBER. SO THIS IS WHY I
WAS ENCOURAGING ENTITIES TO
PLEASE FILE SOONER OR THIS IS
EVEN BETTER. THE IRS HAS THE
SAME FILING DEADLINE AS US. IF
YOU'RE ON A CALENDAR YEAR, IT'S
MAY 15 WHEN YOU FILE THAT IRS
FORM 990 WITH THE IRS. TURN
AROUND, PUT A FORM OUR FORM, THE
RENEWAL FORM FOR THE REGISTRY.
PUT THAT ON TOP. RENEW WITH US
AT THE SAME TIME, IT'S I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW, WE ARE TRYING OUR
BEST WITHIN THE GIVEN THE NUMBER
OF STAFF WE HAVE AT THE REGISTRY
AND THE VOLUME OF ENTITIES THAT
ARE OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND, YOU KNOW, ANY GIVEN TIME,
ENTITIES STILL FALL INTO
DELINQUENCY. SO BUT WE'RE STILL
DOING CUSTOMER SERVICE FOR THE
ONES MAJORITY OF THEM ARE NOT
DELINQUENT. WE'RE STILL
PROVIDING CUSTOMER SERVICE FOR
THEM TO PROCESS THEIR PAPERWORK
SO THEY STAY CURRENT IN THEIR
REGISTRATION. WE'RE HELPING THE
ONES THAT WANT TO FUNDRAISE
THROUGH RAFFLES. IT'S A
DIFFERENT REGISTRATION PROCESS.
SO WE HAVE THIS WHOLE WIDE
PROGRAM, EACH PROGRAM DOING
DIFFERENT THINGS. AND SO
ALTHOUGH WE DO DEVOTE MOST
NUMBER OF REGISTRY STAFF TOWARDS
FIXING DELINQUENCIES, WE I MEAN,
35% OF THE REGISTERED STAFF IS
TRYING TO HELP THEM FIX
DELINQUENCY AND RENEWAL. IT DOES
TAKE TIME BECAUSE IT IS NOT A
CHECKBOX REVIEW. IT IS A
COMPLIANCE REVIEW. DOJ IS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICE. WE NEED TO
DO LAW VIOLATION CHECKS. AND SO,
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
CHARITIES AND WE WORK WITH
CHARITIES. WE'RE TRYING TO
UPSTREAM TO EDUCATE. IN FACT, I
WAS EDUCATING, DOING A
PRESENTATION THIS MORNING WITH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE,
AND I HEARD THAT OVER 700
PARTICIPANTS RSVP FOR THAT
EVENT. SO I'M HOPING THAT TODAY,
LIKE MORE MESSAGE WAS SENT TO
CHARITIES. WE PARTNER WITH
NON-PROFITS TO SPREAD THE WORD.
I SPEAK AT BAR ASSOCIATIONS, AT
DIFFERENT CONFERENCES. WE'RE
TRYING TO SPREAD THE WORD ON
COMPLIANCE SO THAT YOU DON'T
FALL INTO DELINQUENCY. THANK
YOU. AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO CHAIR HART. I'M TRYING TO GET
A HANDLE ON THE PERCENTAGES OF
CHARITIES THAT ARE DELINQUENT
REGULARLY OR, YOU KNOW, THE WORK
FLOW OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS ARE
CONFUSING TO ME. YOU HAVE
109,000 APPROXIMATELY CHARITIES
AND TOTAL OPERATIONS. AND THEN
YOU MENTIONED 20,000, RENEWALS
HAPPENING IN MAY, AND THEN
ANOTHER 24,000 HAPPENING IN
NOVEMBER. BUT SOME OF THOSE ARE
DELINQUENT FOLKS WHO SHOULD HAVE
FILED IN MAY. SO I CAN'T ADD UP
ALL THESE NUMBERS TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW MANY FOLKS
REGULARLY ARE DELINQUENT IN THE
SYSTEM ON A GIVEN YEAR. SURE.
OKAY SO, ALL CHARITIES NEED TO
FILE ANNUAL RENEWALS ONCE THERE,
ONCE THERE, ONCE ONCE THEY'RE
REGISTERED. YES. HAVE TO FILE
AND RENEW EVERY YEAR. THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY. SO THE 20,000
NUMBER THAT ELIZABETH WAS
TALKING ABOUT WAS THE INFLOW OF
MAIL FOR THOSE FOR OUR BUSIEST
MONTHS, WHICH ARE NOVEMBER AND
MAY. SO THE MATERIALS WERE
RECEIVING RUNS 2020 2000.
WHEREAS ON A NORMAL MONTH IT'S
AROUND 9000. SO WHAT SHE'S
INDICATING IS THAT IF SOMEONE IS
SUBMITTING SUBMITTING
DELINQUENCY MATERIALS DURING
THOSE TWO BUSY MONTHS, IT'S
GOING TO BE IT'S GOING TO BE
CONTENDING WITH A LOT OF OTHER
MATERIALS COMING IN AT THE SAME
TIME. I SEE IT'S A SURGE. YES,
EXACTLY. A REGULAR AMOUNT THAT
HAPPENS EVERY MONTH. RIGHT. SO
ON ANY GIVEN YEAR, WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF CHARITIES ARE
DELINQUENT? SO AGAIN, YOU KNOW,
THESE NUMBERS ARE DYNAMIC. BUT
SO LET'S JUST USE FOR
CONVERSATION'S SAKE THAT OUR
CURRENT REGISTERED POPULATION IS
107,000. RIGHT NOW APPROXIMATELY
31% OR 34,000 ARE DELINQUENT.
AND THAT'S A DYNAMIC NUMBER. IT
GOES UP AND DOWN. BUT, 60,
APPROXIMATELY 67 OR 67% ARE
CURRENT. AND THERE'S A SMALL
SEGMENT WHICH IS WHICH WE CALL
OTHER, AND THAT'S PENDING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE PENDING
TO DISSOLVE OR THEIR, TRUST
ACCOUNTS. SO SO THEY'RE KIND OF
IN THAT GRAY AREA AND WE JUST
CATEGORIZE THEM AS OTHER. BUT
THE CORE POPULATION, IT'S ABOUT
A 6731 CONCENTRATION, 31 BEING
DELINQUENT. OKAY. SO ABOUT TWO
THIRDS EVERYTHING WORKS
SMOOTHLY. YES. ONLINE OR LESS.
AND TO SOME DEGREE, I LIKE TO
USE THIS ANALOGY IN SOME WAYS
YOU CAN LOOK AT IT AS A DEBT
PORTFOLIO. SO YOU HAVE YOUR YOUR
DEBTORS WHO ARE IN DEEP TROUBLE,
OR YOU HAVE YOUR CHARITIES THAT
ARE IN DEEP TROUBLE. MAYBE
THEY'RE FOUR YEARS DELINQUENT,
BUT THEN YOU HAVE SOME THAT ARE
JUST MAYBE NOT AS TIGHT ON THEIR
SUBMISSION. AND SO THEY'LL BE
DELINQUENT AND THEN THEY'LL
CURE. SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S ALL OF
THIS POPULATION RUNS THE
SPECTRUM OF, YOU KNOW, NUMBER OF
YEARS DELINQUENT, BUT AS
ELIZABETH MENTIONED, WHEN WE GET
INTO MULTIYEAR, IT BECOMES, YOU
KNOW, IT DOES REALLY CREATE A
LOT OF EXTRA TIME TO DO THE FULL
REVIEW AND TO GET THEM BACK ON
TRACK. AND I IMAGINE HANDLING
ALL THAT PAPERWORK IS
CHALLENGING. AND THERE'S A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF THINGS
THAT JUST GET LOST BECAUSE OF
THAT HUMAN ELEMENT OF OPENING
MAIL AND FILING THINGS, AND
THAT'S, I THINK, WHY YOU'RE
HOPING TO MOVE MORE ONLINE,
RIGHT? SO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
PHYSICAL AS MUCH PHYSICAL VOLUME
OF MAIL. RIGHT RIGHT. SO ONE
GOOD THING ABOUT COVID IS THAT
IT WE WERE DOING ALL OUR IMAGING
BACK END WITH COVID. WE WERE,
YOU KNOW, FORCED BY NECESSITY TO
DO THE IMAGING UP FRONT. AND SO
IT IS A GOOD MODEL. AND, THROUGH
OUR TECHNOLOGY PROJECT, WE WILL
DEFINITELY WANT TO GET
EVERYTHING ON THE FRONT END. BUT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE IMAGING
IT. IT WILL BE DELIVERED TO US
FROM THE CHARITY AS AN IMAGED
DOCUMENT AND NOT A PAPER
DOCUMENT. SO THAT REALLY IS THE
IDEAL SCENARIO IN THE SENSE THAT
IT'S IDEAL FOR THE PUBLIC, IN
THE SENSE IT WILL EXPEDITE THEIR
SUBMISSION, THEY CAN ACTUALLY
TRACK IT BETTER, BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, THEY'LL HAVE THEIR EMAIL
RECEIPT AND SO FORTH VERSUS THE
US MAIL, SO IT WILL ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ISSUES YOU BROUGHT OUT AS
FAR AS LOST MATERIALS. IT'LL
IT'LL ACCELERATE THE TIMELINE AS
FAR AS THE END TO END WHEN, WHEN
WE GET IT AND THEN WHEN WE CAN
GET WORKING ON IT. AND THEN IT
ALSO ACCELERATES THE WORKFLOW IN
THE SENSE THAT WE'RE NOT HAVING
TO OPEN AN ENVELOPE AND POST A
CHECK AND, CðC A DOCUMENT AND
THEN UPLOAD IT. SO THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE HEADED. AND WHEN ARE YOU
HOPING TO HAVE THAT, FULLY
OPERATIONAL? WHAT IS THE
TIMETABLE FOR THAT? PHASE TWO IS
TARGETED FOR SUMMER OF NEXT
YEAR. OKAY. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HART I WANTED TO, GO BACK
TO THE POINT ABOUT MAYBE MAIL
GETTING LOST. WE HAVE NOT HEARD
OF ANY LIKE, ONCE IT GETS TO THE
REGISTRY, ONCE IT COMES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, IT'S NOT
LOST WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. BUT
SOMETIMES WE'LL ASK THEM. THEY
SAY WE SENT IT IN. I SAID, WHAT
ADDRESS DID YOU USE? AND
SOMETIMES IT ENDS UP GOING TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE OR IT
GOES TO DIFFERENT GOVERNMENT
OFFICES. SO WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT
THE MODERNIZATION WILL HELP FIX
THAT. BUT WE ALSO WANT TO BE
MINDFUL OF THOSE SMALLER
CHARITIES THAT MAYBE ARE NOT
SAVVY ENOUGH TO DO FILING
ONLINE. WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT AVAILABLE FOR THEM TO
STILL FILE PAPERWORK, PAPERWORK
RENEWALS WITH US. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. DOCTOR
JACKSON, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND, THANK YOU, BOTH SENATOR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING. YOU KNOW, I CAME
DIRECTLY AS A CEO FROM A
NONPROFIT, STRAIGHT FROM, RIGHT
TO HERE TO SACRAMENTO. SO I'M
FAMILIAR WITH THEIR FORMS. I
PERSONALLY FILL THEM ALL OUT, I
THINK THE ISSUE IS. AND I'M NOT
SURE IF IT'S JUST IT'S JUST IT'S
NOT YOUR FAULT AS YOU'RE DOING
YOUR JOB AND WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN
CALLED TO DO. BUT I THINK WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE ENTIRE NONPROFIT
ECOSYSTEM IN TERMS OF WHAT HAS
TO BE DONE WITH THE IRS, WHAT
HAS TO BE DONE WITH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD, WHAT HAS TO
BE DONE WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE, AND NOW WHAT HAS TO BE
DONE WITH YOU AND THE FACT THAT
YOU KNOW, NONPROFITS ARE, HAVING
TO NAVIGATE ALL OF THAT. I
THINK, IS INCUMBENT UPON
PROBABLY, MAYBE, PROBABLY US AS
A LEGISLATURE TO SIMPLIFY A LOT
OF ALL THOSE PROCESSES, BECAUSE,
FOR INSTANCE, IF, WHEN WE SEND
IT TO THE IRS, I MEAN, THOSE ARE
PUBLIC DOCUMENTS TOO, CORRECT?
YES. SO WHY CAN'T YOU GET THOSE
DOCUMENTS FROM THE IRS AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING THE NONPROFIT
HAVING TO DO ALL OF THAT?
BECAUSE NOW MY NONPROFIT, I HAVE
A WHOLE FINANCE TEAM. THEY COULD
DO THAT EASILY AND ALL THAT
STUFF. BUT IF I'M STILL A ONE
PERSON, I'M JUST TRYING TO
COLLECT SOME TOYS AND GIVE IT TO
SOME KIDS. RIGHT THAT'S A LOT.
AND I HAVE A FULL TIME JOB WHILE
I'M AT IT, AND I'M DOING ALL
THIS TYPE OF THINGS AND, YOU
KNOW, SO, SO THE SAME DOCUMENTS
YOU'RE REQUESTING, EVEN OTHER
STATE STATE DEPARTMENTS ALREADY
HAVE THOSE DOCUMENTS, BUT IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE YOU ALL ARE
TALKING TO EACH OTHER, BECAUSE
WE ALSO HAVE TO FILL OUT. I
THINK IT'S EVERY TWO YEARS WITH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE IN TERMS
OF UPDATING OUR OFFICERS AND
THOSE TYPE OF THINGS. AND SO THE
IDEA IS IRS SAYS WE ARE ACTIVE
AND IN COMPLIANCE. SECRETARY OF
STATE SAYS WE ARE ACTIVE AND IN
COMPLIANCE. FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
SAYS WE ARE IN COMPLIANCE
BECAUSE WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING.
BUT BECAUSE YOU DON'T SAY WE'RE
IN COMPLIANCE, WHICH IS
TECHNICALLY, WELL, ANYWAY,
BECAUSE YOU GUYS SAY YOU'RE
WE'RE THEY'RE NOT IN COMPLIANCE
NOW. THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
RECEIVING THAT CONTRACT NOW.
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO DOING
THOSE THINGS. AND SO IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE'S SOME
REDUNDANCIES THAT SHOULD BE
WORKED OUT SO THAT WE MAKE IT
ACTUALLY EASIER. BECAUSE ONE
THING WE LEARNED FROM THE
PANDEMIC, WHICH IS WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND KIND OF
THE ALL THE HOOPS THAT ARE BEING
JUMPED THROUGH TO BE ABLE TO
STAY IN COMPLIANCE IS THAT IN
MANY CASES, ONE THING WE'VE
LEARNED IS THAT WE NEED MORE
NONPROFITS AND WE ACTUALLY NEED
TO MAKE THE PROCESS EASIER, NOT
HARDER. BECAUSE IRS DOES THEIR
AUDITS FROM TIME TO TIME AS
WELL, RIGHT? I MEAN, FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD, RIGHT? I MEAN, I
REMEMBER ONE TIME, AS I WAS
RENEWING A NONPROFIT THAT HAD
BECOME DELINQUENT, RIGHT? I
MEAN, THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE TO
DO TO GET THAT BABY OUT OF
DELINQUENCY WITH THE IRS IS JUST
SOMETHING TERRIBLE, RIGHT? SO
ALL I'M SAYING IS, IS THAT,
NUMBER ONE, I THINK WE PROBABLY
NEED TO WORK ON HOW DO WE REALLY
SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS FOR A
NONPROFIT IN CALIFORNIA? I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOUR LEGAL
RESPONSE. I KNOW Y'ALL SOME
LAWYERS. I AIN'T TRYING TO TELL
YOU. I KNOW WHAT Y'ALL ARE JUST
TRYING TO DO THE BEST YOU CAN IN
TERMS OF MAKING SURE YOU'RE
DOING YOUR JOB AND ALL THOSE
TYPE OF THINGS. BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TOTAL ECOSYSTEM AND
I'M WONDERING, DO YOU HAVE AN
ADVISORY BOARD OF NONPROFITS
THAT ADVISE YOU ALL ON THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND, AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT THEY HAVE
TO DO WITH AND BY YOU CREATING
ONE REQUIREMENT OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, HOW THAT WOULD AFFECT
FOLKS, PARTICULARLY IF YOU'RE A
NONPROFIT UNDER $50,000. RIGHT
THAT IS THAT'S SOME SERIOUS,
SERIOUS WORK THAT THAT HAS TO BE
DONE. NO, WE DON'T HAVE AN
ADVISORY BOARD, BUT WE DO HAVE A
GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING
NONPROFITS, FROM WHICH WE
RECEIVE FEEDBACK AND FOR WHICH
WE SEEK FEEDBACK FOR VARIOUS
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT THAT COME
UP. AND I DO UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. THERE IS A LOT
THAT CHARITIES HAVE TO DO, AND
THEY DO IMPORTANT WORK IN OUR
STATE. WE WANT MORE CHARITIES TO
OPERATE SUCCESSFULLY AND TO
FLOURISH IN THIS ENVIRONMENT. I
DO WANT TO POINT OUT, THOUGH,
WHEN SMALLER CHARITIES ARE
FILING FORM 999, WHICH IS THE
E-POSTCARD WITH THE IRS, WE GET
NO DATA FROM THAT. AND SO EVEN
THOUGH YOU THINK IT'S ONLY
$50,000 CHARITY, MANY OF THE
SMALLER CHARITIES ARE NOT
OPERATING PROPERLY. AND I THINK
THAT THEY NEED HELP. AND SO
MAYBE IF WE SPOT ISSUE SPOT SOME
OF THESE, YOU KNOW, LEGAL
VIOLATIONS, WE COULD WORK WITH
THEM TO CORRECT IT AND PUT
BETTER PROCESSES. WHAT DO YOU
MEAN BY LEGAL VIOLATIONS? THOSE
ARE NOT LEGAL VIOLATIONS. NO, NO.
WHAT I'M SAYING IF WE, FOR
INSTANCE, LIKE SO WE REQUIRE THE
ONES THAT FILE 999 TO DO A K¾T
ONE. SO WE JUST GET A BROADER
PICTURE OF THEIR FINANCES. SO
IF, FOR INSTANCE, WE GET A
COMPLAINT COMING IN, WE SAW, OH,
IT'S A SMALLER CHARITY, BUT WE
SEE THAT WHERE THEY COULD
IMPROVE THEIR PROCESS, WE CAN
SAY, OH, I THINK WE COULD
RECOMMEND THIS CORRECTIVE ACTION
FOR YOU. SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT PUT THEM. BUT IF THEY DON'T
THEY'RE PENALIZED FOR IT. NO, WE
DON'T FILE. WE'RE NOT FILING A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THEM. WE'RE
GIVING THEM A GUIDANCE AS TO HOW
TO MAKE YOUR PROCESS BETTER. SO
ON THE LEGAL SIDE, IT'S NOT
ALWAYS PENALIZING. WE DO WORK
WITH THEM TO WE DON'T WANT TO
HARM THEIR REPUTATION. WE WORK
WITH THEM TO CORRECT THE, THEIR
MANAGEMENT, THEIR OPERATIONS SO
THAT THEY STAY IN COMPLIANCE.
MAYBE WE'RE SAYING YOU MAYBE
HAVE A BETTER POLICY IN PLACE
ABOUT WHEN YOU HOLD BOARD
MEETINGS, HAVE A HAVE THAT
BINDER THAT I TALKED ABOUT HAVE
A BINDER THAT GOES TO EVERY
BOARD MEETING. AND PEOPLE LOOK
AT IT WHEN OUR FILINGS DO SO,
SOME OF THE PROCESSES THAT MAY
BE MISSING FROM A SMALLER
CHARITY, BECAUSE THEY WENT AND
WENT INTO IT, THEY STARTED A
CHARITY WITH, YOU KNOW, GOOD
INTENTIONS. THEY WANT TO GO OUT
AND HELP. BUT THERE ARE ALL
THESE OBLIGATIONS, IN ADDITION
TO GETTING TAX EXEMPT STATUS AND
FORMING A NONPROFIT, FOR
INSTANCE, YOU DO HAVE TO OPERATE
WITH TRANSPARENCY, RIGHT? THAT'S
WHAT THE THAT'S WHAT THE
AUTHORITY THAT'S WHAT THE
LEGISLATOR TOLD THE AG TO DO.
MAKE SURE YOU MAKE THESE FILINGS
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC. YOU GET
IT FROM THEM AND GIVE IT TO THEM
AND MAKE IT AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC SO THAT THE DONORS COULD
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS,
DECISIONS AND SEE WHAT THAT
CHARITY IS DOING. SO WE WANT TO
HELP THEM, OKAY. AND PART OF
HELPING THEM IS ALSO WE NEED TO
SEE HOW THEY'RE OPERATING. WE
NEED TO SEE SOME TRANSPARENCY
WITH THE FILINGS THAT THEY DO.
YEAH I MEAN AGAIN I'M NOT
FAULTING YOU FOR YOU DOING THE
BEST YOU CAN WITH YOUR WORK AND
YOUR, YOUR WHAT YOU SEE AS YOUR
LEGAL OBLIGATION AND ALL THOSE
TYPE OF THINGS I THINK IS EVEN
MORE JUST INCUMBENT UPON US,
EVEN AS A LEGISLATURE, TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN SIMPLIFY THE
PROCESS. WHAT ARE SOME
DUPLICATIONS THAT ARE THAT WE'RE
SEEING HAPPENING? BECAUSE MORE
THAN EVER, WE NEED MORE
NONPROFITS. I DO AGREE THEY NEED
MORE ASSISTANCE TO HELP THEM
TURN THOSE IDEAS INTO PROGRAMS,
THOSE PROGRAMS INTO
ORGANIZATIONS AND THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THE
INSTITUTIONS IN OUR COMMUNITY TO
HELP WITH THE HEAVY LIFTING THAT
EXISTS WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
ALL THOSE TYPE OF THINGS, TOO.
BUT DEFINITELY APPRECIATE IT.
THANKS ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS, I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL AS PANELISTS, AS EXPERTS
TO HELP US UNDERSTAND THIS. AND
THIS IS, EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
HOPING REALLY TO ENGAGE AND TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO IMPROVE,
RIGHT. BOTH IMPROVE FOR YOU ALL
THAT SERVE A ROLE IN MAKING SURE
THAT FOLKS ARE COMPLIANT, THAT
WE, YOU KNOW, THAT THE THAT WHEN
WE PLACE TRUST, IN GIVING A
DOLLAR, IT'S GOING TO WHERE IT'S
GOING AND THAT FOLKS ARE DOING
BUT ALSO TO ENSURE RIGHT THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO DELIVER THE
OUTCOMES THAT MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES MOVE IN THE WAY AND
ADVANCE IN THE WAY THAT I THINK
IS IMPORTANT. SO VERY HELPFUL. I
THINK VERY CREATIVE IDEAS HAVE
COME UP JUST IN THE FIRST PANEL.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME OUR SECOND PANEL. I
DON'T HAVE ANY.
THANK YOU. SO OUR SECOND PANEL
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION OF ADVANCED
PAYMENTS. AND THAT IS A BILL
THAT MY COLLEAGUE HERE AND CHAIR
HART HAD. AND WE HAVE JEFF GREEN,
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF CAL
NONPROFITS. WE HAVE AMAR
AZUCENA, CID, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY INVESTMENTS AND
PLANNING FOR CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL. SUSAN
GÓMEZ, CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE, AND SANDRA SELDEN,
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF FRESNO BUILDING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES. SO I WILL
SAY THAT YOU EACH HAVE FIVE
MINUTES, WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
AMAR, WHO I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE JUST A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
TO. SO WE'LL KICK IT OFF WITH
JEFF GREEN. GREAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU, CHAIRWOMAN
LEMON. AND CHAIRMAN HEART AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SO I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE AS PART OF
THIS HEARING TODAY AS TO
REPRESENT THE VOICE OF THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS CEO OF
THE ASSOCIATION AND ALSO BETTER
KNOWN AS CAL NONPROFITS. AND I
GET TO WORK ALONGSIDE SOME
10,000 NONPROFIT MEMBERS AND
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS
WE STRIVE TO PROTECT AND ENHANCE
THE ABILITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
NONPROFITS TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR STATE, AND
ESPECIALLY THROUGH OUR PUBLIC
POLICY AND ADVOCACY WORK,
THROUGHOUT ALL OF OUR POLICY
EFFORTS, WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING INEQUALITIES AND
INEQUITIES AND SUPPORTING
EFFORTS TO BRING MORE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND TO THE SECTOR AS
A WHOLE. AND WITH THAT LENS,
WE'RE PARTICULARLY PROUD TO BE
CHIEF PROPONENT OF IN YOUR
COLLABORATOR ON WHAT WE DEEM THE
TERM THE NONPROFIT EQUITY
INITIATIVE. AND THIS WAS TO
IMPROVE STATE GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTING PRACTICES WITH A
FOCUS ON FAIRNESS, EFFICIENCY
AND STABILITY FOR THE SECTOR
ITSELF. MORE THAN 550 NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY LEADERS ACROSS THE
STATE SIGNED ON TO SUPPORT THIS
EFFORT, AND A GROUP OF ABOUT TWO
DOZEN NONPROFITS ORGANIZED AS A
LOOSELY AFFILIATED CONTRACTING
COALITION TO DEVELOP AND ADVANCE
A PACKAGE OF BILLS. AND THESE
WERE THE FIRST SEVEN WHICH WERE
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR. AT THE
BEGINNING OF 2023. THE
INITIATIVE AND THE WORK WE'VE
DONE SINCE IS A TESTAMENT TO THE
VALUE OF YOUR SELECT COMMITTEES.
FOR ONE, THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT EMERGED FROM THE FEBRUARY
2022 JOINT HEARING ACTUALLY LED
DIRECTLY TO THE LAUNCH OF THE
NONPROFIT EQUITY INITIATIVE, AND
THE TESTIMONY IN THAT HEARING
SHINED A VERY BRIGHT LIGHT ON
THE NEED TO COLLECTIVELY ADDRESS
CONTRACTING PRACTICES THROUGH
LEGISLATIVE INTERVENTIONS. AS
THE STATUS QUO HAS LONG CREATED
COSTS AND INEQUITIES FOR
NONPROFITS TRYING TO PARTNER
WITH THE STATE TO MEET ALL KINDS
OF COMMUNITY NEEDS. TODAY, WE'RE
HERE TO BUILD ON THE
INITIATIVE'S SUCCESS IN PASSING
ASSEMBLY BILL 590, WHICH WAS
AUTHORED BY CHAIR HART, PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND SIGNED INTO LAW JUST LAST
YEAR. AB 590 IMPROVES AND
EXPANDS THE CRITICAL PRACTICE OF
PROVIDING NONPROFITS WITH
STARTUP FUNDS, ALSO KNOWN AS
ADVANCE PAYMENT, ON ALL STATE
GRANTS AND CONTRACTS, BY
AUTHORIZING UP TO 25% ADVANCE
PAY. THE LEGISLATION ENSURES
THAT NONPROFITS DO NOT HAVE TO
FRONT SIGNIFICANT EXPENSES AND
THEN WAIT TO BE REIMBURSED, BE
FORCED TO TAKE ON HIGH INTEREST
LOANS, WHICH IS ONE STRATEGY OF
DEALING WITH THAT IN ORDER TO
LAUNCH NEW PROGRAMS OR BE
EXCLUDED FROM CONTRACTS AND
GRANTS BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
ACCESS TO THE UPFRONT CAPITAL
NECESSARY. AND IT'S MADE
NECESSARY BY THAT REIMBURSEMENT
ONLY MODEL AB 590 CLARITY THAT
ADVANCE PAYMENTS UP TO 25% ARE
NOT ONLY PERMISSIBLE, BUT AN
EXPECTED NORM CREATES THE
POTENTIAL TO ENABLE MORE
NONPROFITS, PARTICULARLY THOSE
WITH LESS CASH ON HAND AND THOSE
LED BY OR SERVING POOR, RURAL
MAJORITY PEOPLE OF COLOR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE TO
PARTNER WITH STATE GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S WHY THE WAY IN WHICH THE
STATE AGENCIES CONTRACT WITH
NONPROFITS IS A QUESTION OF
EQUITY. FOR US, AND NOT ONLY FOR
NONPROFIT CONTRACTORS, BUT ALSO
FOR, OF COURSE, THE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE. THE
OBJECTIVE OF THIS PANEL
DISCUSSION TODAY IS TO ENSURE
BROAD, STATEWIDE IMPLEMENTATION
OF AB 590, THE BILL'S PERMISSIVE
NATURE. AS YOU'RE ALL AWARE,
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR ALL TO MAKE
USE OF THE ADVANCE PAYMENT
MODEL, BUT NONE ARE REQUIRED TO
DO SO. SO THE QUESTION IS, HOW
DO WE SPREAD THE WORD ACROSS
STATE GOVERNMENT ABOUT THE
BENEFITS BOTH TO THE STATE AND
THE CONTRACTORS AND THE
GRANTEES? SO THAT ADVANCE PAY
ACTUALLY BECOMES THE NORM IN
CALIFORNIA? YOU APPROVED THE
LEGISLATION BECAUSE YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT ADVANCE PAY
ADDRESSES LONG STANDING
CONTRACTING PRACTICES THAT OFTEN
MAKE PARTNERSHIP TOO EXPENSIVE
FOR MANY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS, ESPECIALLY
SMALLER ONES. AND THAT SHOULD
NOT DETER OUR MUTUAL EFFORTS TO
DELIVER THE HIGHEST QUALITY
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WITHOUT
WIDESPREAD IMPLEMENTATION OF
ADVANCE PAY ACROSS THE STATE, WE
RISK UNNECESSARY CAPACITY AND
RESOURCE LIMITATIONS CONTINUING
TO BE A STRAIN ON NONPROFITS
ABILITIES TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES, ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
MORE UNDER-RESOURCED AREAS. THE
REALITY THAT MANY NONPROFITS
PARTNERING WITH GOVERNMENT MUST
FUND RAISE TO SUBSIDIZE THE TRUE
COST OF THESE MUCH NEEDED GRANT
PROGRAMS, BECAUSE GOVERNMENT
DOLLARS SIMPLY DO NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH TO RELATIVE TO THE REAL
NEED. IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE PASSAGE OF AB 590
GENERATED NATIONAL RECOGNITION
OF THE STATE'S LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. OTHER NONPROFIT
ASSOCIATIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
AND I GET THOSE PHONE CALLS, ARE
PURSUING OPPORTUNITIES TO
EMULATE AB 590, AND THEY'RE
CURRENTLY EXPLORATORY
CONVERSATIONS AROUND POTENTIAL
NATIONAL LEGISLATION AS WELL. SO
TRUE TO THE FAMILIAR SAYING, AS
GOES CALIFORNIA. SO GOES THE
NATION, OBVIOUSLY ALL EYES ARE
ON US TO ENSURE THAT AB 590 IS
FULL, POTENTIAL IS MET. AND HOW
WILL WE MEET THE MOMENT AND RISE
TO THAT OCCASION? SO THAT THE
MODEL WE'VE CREATED FOR OTHERS
TO FOLLOW IS SUCCESSFUL FROM
START TO FINISH? IT'S WORTH
ADDING THAT THE STATE ALREADY
HAS MANY SUCCESSFUL, PROVEN
EXAMPLES OF THE BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH ADVANCE PAY. IT
IS NOT A NEW OR RADICAL IDEA FOR
EXAMPLE, IN 2017, AB 1534
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
AUTHORED CALFIRE AUTHORIZED CAL
FIRE TO PROVIDE ADVANCE PAYMENTS
UNDER ITS URBAN COMMUNITY
FORESTRY PROGRAM, AND THIS
ALLOWED 214 GRANTEES TO ACCESS
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO
COMPLETE WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
OR FOREST HEALTH PROJECTS. A
REPORT ANALYZING THE IMPACT OF
USING ADVANCE PAY FOR CAL FIRE
STATED THAT THE GRANTEES WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO OPERATE
WITHOUT GRANT PAYMENT ADVANCES,
AS THEY COULD NOT AFFORD TO FUND
THE WORK WITHOUT THOSE VERY
ADVANCES. CLEARLY, ADVANCE PAY
EXPANDS THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
NONPROFITS IN THIS PROGRAM,
ALLOWING COMMITTED COMMUNITY
GROUPS WITH LOW OR NO BUDGET TO
IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE IN THEIR
REGIONS. ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS IN
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FIELD.
SERVICES ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
PERFORMED IN CALIFORNIA BY
NONPROFITS, AND LIKE MANY, THEY
FACE FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS THROUGH
THE STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT
MODEL, WHICH IMPACTED SERVICE
DELIVERY. ASSEMBLY BILL 673 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS WAS
ADOPTED TO ENSURE THAT THESE
SERVICE PROVIDERS ACTUALLY
RECEIVE THE ENTIRETY OF THEIR
STATE GRANTS UP FRONT, AND THESE
TWO EXAMPLES ARE JUST TWO. BUT
THEY SHOW THAT WHILE ADVANCE PAY
IS CLEARLY SUCCESSFUL WHEN
IMPLEMENTED, A PIECEMEAL
APPROACH IS SIMPLY GOING TO BE
INEFFICIENT AND INSUFFICIENT. AB
590 ENABLES LARGE SCALE ADOPTION
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE AND UNIFORM
PROCESSES, AVOID GOVERNMENT
WASTE, AND ENHANCE NONPROFIT
STABILITY. AND IF WE NÓ ADVANCE
PAY PRODUCES STRONG RESULTS FROM
THESE TWO EXAMPLES AND THE MANY
OTHERS ACROSS THE AGENCY OVER
THE YEARS, AND IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON US AS LEADERS TO DO WHAT IT
TAKES TO MOVE PAST THE STATUS
QUO. SO AT CAL NONPROFITS, WE'RE
WILLING, ABLE, COMMITTED TO WORK
ALONGSIDE YOU MAKING ADVANCE
PAYMENTS. THE DEFAULT ON
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTING RATHER
THAN THE EXCEPTION. WE WOULD
PROPOSE A FEW TOOLS TO ASSIST IN
THIS EFFORT. THAT WOULD INCLUDE
FACILITATING A TRAINING PROGRAM
FOR ALL STATE AGENCIES THROUGH
VARIOUS WEBINARS, ROUNDTABLE OF
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS ON
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGIES, ETC.
THE CREATION OF STANDARDIZED
LANGUAGE IN ADVANCE, PAY FOR
EASIER ADOPTION, AND REGULARLY
TOUTING THE SUCCESSES ACHIEVED
BY EXISTING AND NEW ADVANCE PAY
CONTRACTING TO BRING MORE
ATTENTION TO THE BENEFITS.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GOING TO TAKE ALL
OF US WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE
AB 590 PROMISE A REALITY, AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO BRINGING FURTHER
ATTENTION TO THIS MATTER. AND WE
OBVIOUSLY WELCOME YOUR IDEAS,
THE HANDS ON INVOLVEMENT IN HOW
WE DO THIS. SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR PROVIDING THIS
PLATFORM TO CONSIDER OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND MAKING FURTHER
PROGRESS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF ADVANCE PAY SO THAT
NONPROFITS AND STATE AGENCIES
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP ARE WELL
POSITIONED TO THRIVE AND MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
AND NEXT, WE'LL HAVE AMAR,
SUSANA, CID. HELLO. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, SO I'M GOING
TO LEAD, WITH HOW WE OPERATE
RIGHT NOW AT THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL, COMMUNITIES
FACING EXISTING INEQUITIES ARE
OFTEN MOST VULNERABLE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND OTHER DISASTERS AND
LEAST EQUIPPED TO RESPOND. THE
STATE, LIKE THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL AND OUR PARTNERING
AGENCIES, OFFER PROGRAMS AND
PROVIDE PROGRAM OPPORTUNITIES TO
REDUCE LOCAL POLLUTION,
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS, AND
INCREASE EQUITY AND RESILIENCE
ACROSS THE STATE. THIS IS
INCLUDING ADDRESSING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES. STATES ARE ALSO LOOKING
AT AND PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT ARE ESSENTIAL
AND FOUNDATIONAL TO ENSURING
UNDER-RESOURCED COMMUNITIES CAN
ACCESS AND WILL ACCESS TOOLS,
RESOURCES AND FUNDING NECESSARY
FOR ONGOING TRANSFORMATION. THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL MOVED
TO COUNCIL PRIORITY 2 IN 2022,
WHICH IS ADVANCING CAPACITY
BUILDING AS A KEY EQUITY
STRATEGY. THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL ADOPTED A RESOLUTION TO
FURTHER PROMOTE AND INTEGRATE
CAPACITY BUILDING ACROSS THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL AND OUR
MEMBER AGENCIES AND OUR
INITIATIVES. THE RESOLUTION
BUILDS ON THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
COUNCIL BY EXPANDING AND
EXTENDING OUR COMMITMENT TO
ADVANCING CAPACITY BUILDING
ACROSS THE STATE AND IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT MORE COMMUNITIES
ACCESSING FUNDS THAT ARE
CRITICAL FOR IMPLEMENTATION,
ESPECIALLY AROUND CLIMATE
POLICY. THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL HAS INCORPORATED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS A KEY
STRATEGY ACROSS MANY OF OUR
PROGRAMS. SINCE 2016, WE PILOTED
THIS BACK IN 2016 AND 2017 WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM,
AS WELL AS PARTNERING WITH OUR
AGENCIES SUCH AS CAL ESTÁ, THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
AND ITS MEMBER AGENCIES.
CALTRANS, ON THEIR CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS, WITH THE
LCITP, WHICH IS THE LOW CARBON
TRANSIT OPERATIONS PROGRAM, AND
THE TRANS INTERSTATE RAIL
CAPITAL PROGRAM. THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL RELEASED OUR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GUIDANCE
BACK IN 2020, UPDATED THAT
GUIDANCE IN 2023. IN THIS
GUIDANCE, WE EXPANDED ON AREAS
WHERE STATE AGENCIES CAN IMPROVE
CAPACITY BUILDING THROUGH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE DEVELOPMENT
ACROSS THEIR PROGRAMS. THIS
INCLUDES MANY INITIATIVES THAT
EXPAND AND ENHANCE RESOURCES FOR
COMMUNITIES AND ABILITY TO
ACCESS CAPITAL. I LEAD WITH
CAPACITY BUILDING AS THAT IS A
MAINSTAY FOR OUR WORK. OUR EARLY
INVESTMENTS IN OUR WORK TAKEN BY
THESE ACTIONS HAS LED OUR
COUNCIL TO CHAMPION PRIORITIES
ON EXPANDING COMMUNITY VOICE
RESEARCH, TAKEN THROUGH OUR
PARTNERS AND OUR INSTITUTIONS
THAT SUPPORTED ADVANCE PAYMENT
AS A STRATEGY TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO FUNDING THAT SUPPORTED THAT
SUPPORT LOW RESOURCE COMMUNITIES
AND ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE. THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT
GRANT APPLICATIONS WHO DO NOT
ALREADY HAVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND CAPACITY BUILDING
SUPPORT OR STRATEGIES DO NOT
COMPETE WELL FOR FUNDING OUR
STRATEGIC SUPPORT IN THESE AREAS
HELP ALIGN AND SUPPORT
APPLICATIONS TO GET TO THE
NEEDED AREAS AND RESOURCES. BY
PROVIDING THESE PATHWAYS AND
STRATEGIC SUPPORT, APPLICANTS
ARE ABLE TO ALIGN WITH OUR
PRIORITIES, SUCH AS OUR RACIAL
EQUITY ACTION PLAN AND OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN. SOME OF OUR
EARLY AWARDEES WITHIN THEIR
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM EXPRESSED
THE COMPLICATIONS OF
IMPLEMENTING INTERSECTIONAL
PROJECTS AND HIGH COST
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHOUT UPFRONT
FUNDING OR DOWN PAYMENTS FOR
COLLATERAL. THIS CAUSED SOME
PARTNERS TO TAKE OUT LOANS TO
ADVANCE THEIR PROJECTS UNTIL
THEY COULD BE REIMBURSED. THE
ADVANCE PAY LEGISLATION. INTENT
HERE IS FOR ALIGNMENT. THE WAY
WE SEE IT IN OUR CAPACITY
BUILDING WORK TO ASSIST
CALIFORNIA TRIBES AND
UNDER-RESOURCED COMMUNITIES BY
REDUCING ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS
AND PROVIDING TARGETED SUPPORT
STRUCTURES TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
THAT STATE. FUNDING. SOME OF OUR
EXAMPLES THAT WE'VE UNDERGONE
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
AND MORE RECENTLY, ARE LOOKING
AT HOW WE IMPLEMENT THE
LEGISLATION FOR ADVANCE PAY
RIGHT NOW. WE'RE ALSO
UNDERSTANDING, AS PARTNER PANEL
MEMBERS MENTIONED, THERE ARE
STATE AGENCIES THAT HAVE
OPERATED ADVANCE PAY OUTSIDE OF
THIS LEGISLATION. ONE OTHER
EXAMPLE IS CALTRANS OPERATING
THE LOW CARBON TRANSIT OPERATION
PROGRAM. SO WITH THESE EXAMPLES,
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO LOOK AT OUR
OWN PROGRAMING AND FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO MOVE OUR STRATEGIC AREAS
WITH CAPACITY BUILDING AND
ADVANCE PAY. WE HAVE LEGISLATION
THAT HAS ENABLED US TO PILOT
THIS THROUGH THE TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE. COMMUNITIES WE UPDATED
OUR GUIDELINES FOR ROUND FOUR
AND FOR OUR RECENT ROUND. IN
ROUND FIVE LAST YEAR, WE WERE
ABLE TO CURRENTLY DOCUMENT AND
ADVANCE PAYMENT TO THE NATIVE
AMERICAN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION COALITION UNDER
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES, OUR REGIONAL
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES HAS OFFERED
TWO ADVANCED PAYMENTS, ONE
PARTICULARLY TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS THAT IS
SUPPORTING OVER SIX NONPROFITS
AND OUR COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
CENTERS, WHICH WAS JUST AWARDED
IN THE SPRING, IS SIGNING
CONTRACTS RIGHT NOW AND WORKING
ON WORKSHOPS FOR EXPANDING
ADVANCE PAY IN THAT PROJECT OR
THAT PROGRAM. SOME OF OUR
LESSONS LEARNED RIGHT NOW ARE
LOOKING AND MANAGING THE
DIFFERENT LEGISLATIVE PIECES, SO
THAT WE HAVE THE BEST
INFORMATION MOVING FORWARD FOR
OUR PROGRAMS, CERTAIN THINGS
THAT COME UP ARE ELIGIBILITY
ACROSS OUR PROGRAMS, WHETHER IT
BE FOR NONPROFITS, LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TRIBES.
CURRENTLY, WE ARE ADMINISTERING
NON ADVANCE PAY TO NONPROFITS
AND TO LOCAL GOVERNANCE. WE DO
HAVE A TRIBAL LED NONPROFIT THAT
IS RECEIVING ADVANCE PAYMENT
WITH OUR EXPERIENCE OVER THE
LAST YEAR, WE ALSO UNDERGONE
UNDERWENT A DOF AUDIT ON OUR
PILOT FOR ADVANCE PAY. WE ARE
RESPONDING TO SOME OF OUR
FINDINGS, WHICH HAS HELPED THE
COUNCIL REALLY REFINE OUR
PROCEDURES AND REALLY REFINE OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD. WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY RELEASED SOME OF
OUR WORKSHOPS AND OUR TOOLS TO
OUR APPLICANTS OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS. MORE RECENTLY,
THIS WEEK WE HELD AN ADVANCE PAY
WORKSHOP WITH OVER 120
PARTICIPANTS TO GO THROUGH HOW
TO RECEIVE ADVANCE PAY, WHAT ARE
THE TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO DO SO?
WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW IS
FURTHER REFINING OUR PROCESS AND
PROCEDURES SO THAT WE CAN ADHERE
TO THE LEGISLATION AND BE
ACCOUNTABLE TO OUR FUNDING
MECHANISMS. AGAIN, WE ARE
HOLDING WORKSHOPS ACROSS ALL OF
OUR PROGRAMS THAT ARE UTILIZING
ADVANCE PAY AND PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO HEAR
FROM THE PUBLIC MEMBERS ON WHAT
IS WORKING, WHAT IS NOT WORKING.
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO, AGAIN,
MAKING HEADWAY AS TAKING A
STANCE TO ROOT OUT HISTORIC
INEQUITIES EMBEDDED IN OUR
GOVERNMENT PROCESSES AND
INSTITUTIONS. AND WE ARE
SUPPORTING COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
WORKING HARD TO BUILD CLIMATE
RESILIENCE, LIKE ENACTING
PROGRAMS TO CLEAN UP OUR AIR,
OUR WATER, OUR SOIL. AND WE NEED
TO DO THIS BY MOBILIZING SOME OF
THAT WORK. THEY ARE DOING THIS
BY SUSTAINABLE MOBILITY, OPTION
IMPROVEMENTS, UPDATING, BUILDING
WITH SOLAR AND DOING SO TO
REDUCE BURDEN ON COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. AND WE KNOW
NOW THAT SOME OF THIS WORK IS
DIFFICULT AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE HEARING
COMMUNITY VOICE AND COMMUNITY
LED ORGANIZATIONS AND THAT THEY
ARE AT THE TABLE TO HELP DEVELOP
THESE PROJECTS SO THAT WHEN WE
HAVE SHOVEL READY PROJECTS AND
PROGRAMS THAT ARE REQUIRED, WE
KNOW THAT THEY CAN BE READY TO
DO SO AND IMPLEMENT FASTER HOW
SGC IS DESIGNING OUR PROGRAMS,
LEADING THROUGH CAPACITY
BUILDING STRATEGIES IS IMPROVING
OUR FEDERAL FUNDING LEVERAGE.
MORE RECENTLY, WITH OUR
PROGRAMING, WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL FUNDS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA CCG, WHICH IS THE
CONNECTING. SORRY, IT IS THE
COMMUNITY CHANGE GRANT THAT IS
REALLY REPLICATED AFTER TCC TO
FURTHER EXTEND HOW WE DO
CAPACITY BUILDING AND
PARTNERSHIP THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND SO WE ARE EXCITED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK AND DEEPEN OUR
INVESTMENT, DEEPENING OUR
INVESTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, NEXT WE
WILL GO TO SUSAN GÓMEZ. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MIKE GOOD AFTERNOON,
ESTEEMED CHAIRWOMAN LIMÓN,
CHAIRMAN HART AND MEMBERS OF THE
NONPROFIT, COMMITTEE ON THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR. I AM DEEPLY
HONORED TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
TODAY AS THE CEO OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE.
WE ARE A GROUP OF 109 NONPROFITS
BOTH IN RIVERSIDE AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. AND ICC
SUPPORTS NONPROFITS IN
COLLECTIVELY ADVOCATING AND
MAKING THE REGION MORE EQUITABLE,
DIVERSE, AND JUST THROUGH
CAPACITY BUILDING, OUR
STRATEGIES ARE REALLY AROUND
ADVOCACY AND POLICY WORK. AND
TODAY, THOUGH, I'D LIKE TO SHARE
OUR EXPERIENCE AS IT RELATES TO
ADVANCE PAYMENTS AND THEIR
IMPACT ON OUR ORGANIZATIONAL
OPERATIONS, OUR FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT, AND OUR PROGRAM
DELIVERY, AND I SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF A COALITION OF NOT JUST THE
109, BUT ALMOST 672 NONPROFITS
ALSO THAT WORK ALONGSIDE THE ICC
ADVANCE PAYMENTS HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY BENEFITED OUR
ORGANIZATIONS AND OUR PARTNERS.
THEY'VE ELEVATED OUR FINANCIAL
PRESSURES, ENHANCE OUR
PREDICTABILITY IN FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT, ENABLED AN IMMEDIATE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES AND COMMUNITIES.
AND DESPITE THESE BENEFITS,
THERE CONTINUES TO BE CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION. THE NEED FOR
TRAINING, COORDINATION AND
WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AND NONPROFITS. I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT AB 590, IF FULLY REALIZED,
WILL GREATLY BENEFIT ALL
NONPROFITS, SMALL AND LARGE
ANCHOR ORGANIZATION. BUT IT DOES
REQUIRE CONCERTED EFFORTS TO
PRIORITIZE EDUCATION OR CAPACITY
BUILDING AND EQUITABLE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
POLICIES. THE CRITICAL ROLE OF
ADVANCE PAYMENTS IS REALLY THE
MAXIMUM MAXIMIZING OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE STATES AND
CONTRACTS, THEY PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY CAPITAL. AND I KNOW
JEFF COVERED THAT TO COVER
EXPENSES IN REAL TIME, REDUCING
THE NEED FOR NONPROFITS, DELAYED
PAYMENTS TO CONTRACTORS AND
VENDORS, AND TO SEEK INTEREST
AND TO ELIMINATE HAVING TO SEEK
INTEREST LOANS OR CREDIT CARD
ADVANCES. I HAVE SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES OF MINE THAT, BECAUSE
OF NOT HAVING ADVANCE PAYMENTS,
HAVE HAD MULTIPLE LOANS AND
CREDIT THAT THEY HAVE TO DO IN
ORDER TO PAY THEIR STAFF OR
THEMSELVES AND TO KEEP THEIR
PROGRAMS AND THEIR DOORS OPEN,
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE, THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY 14,331 NONPROFITS
OF THOSE, 67% OF THEM HAVE
BUDGETS OF UNDER $100,000. SO
THE MAJORITY OF US ARE SMALL OUT
THERE IN THE EYE, AND FOR THESE
SMALLER NONPROFITS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE WORKING IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES, ADVANCE PAYMENTS
ARE VITAL. IT IT IT CREATES US
TO HAVE AN EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITY
TO COME AFTER THESE FEDERAL AND
STATE DOLLARS THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE BEFORE. AND I'D JUST LIKE
TO POINT THREE PRIORITIES FOR US
IN TERMS OF DEMONSTRATING THE
BENEFITS. AGAIN, IT'S THE
ADVANCE PAYMENTS HELPS US TO
MAINTAIN STEADY OPERATIONS
WITHOUT DELAYS, WHICH IS CRUCIAL
FOR SMALLER NONPROFITS. AGAIN,
OPERATING WITH TIGHTER BUDGETS.
THE PREDICTABILITY OF FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT, WE CAN PLAN OUR
BUDGETS AND BE MORE ACCURATE
ABOUT ALLOCATING FUNDS WITHOUT
DELAY AND INVEST IN THE CAPACITY
BUILDING ACTIVITIES THAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED AS WELL IN THIS TABLE,
MY COLLEAGUES. BUT AGAIN, I
THINK THE BIGGEST ADVANTAGE IS
SMALLER NONPROFITS AND LEADERS
OF COLOR WILL HAVE MORE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO THESE STATE
GRANTS AND FUNDS. MOST RECENTLY,
ICC APPLIED FOR OUR FIRST STATE
GRANT THROUGH THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AND
STRATEGIC COMMUNICATION. OCFS,
TITLED THE GOVERNOR'S TRUSTED
MESSENGER GRANT, WE DID OUR
FIRST COLLABORATIVE APPLICATION
OF OVER EIGHT NONPROFITS
ALTOGETHER, AN ORGANIZATION
HELPING WITH CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM AND ADULTS, A MUSLIM
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING BASIC
NEEDS. WE HAVE AN ORGANIZATION
UP IN BIG BEAR DOING PARENTING
FOR CHILDREN, IT WAS THE
DIVERSITY AMONGST THE REGION,
BUT COLLECTIVELY, BECAUSE OF
ADVANCE PAYMENTS, ALL THE
PARTICIPATING AGENCIES COULD
IMMEDIATELY START THE PROJECT ON
DAY ONE, INCLUDING HIRING AND
PAYING OUR STAFF. AND WITHOUT
THESE ADVANCE PAYMENTS, AT LEAST
THREE OF THE PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS, DUE TO THEIR
SMALLER BUDGETS, WOULD NEVER
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PARTICIPATE.
SO WE THANK YOU FOR THAT, THE
CHALLENGES, AGAIN, IS THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND WE REALIZE
THIS NEW LEGISLATION WILL
REQUIRE IT IS COMPLEX AND
REQUIRES SIGNIFICANT
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES,
ORGANIZATIONS STRUGGLE TO
INTERPRET AND APPLY FOR THESE
NEW REGULATIONS. I WILL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE. THIS IS COUNTY OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DOES HAVE A
NONPROFIT ROUNDTABLE. THEY'VE
AGREED TO, OFFER THE 25%, BUT
ONLY IF NONPROFITS ASK FOR IT.
SO IT'S AVAILABLE. BUT IF YOU
DON'T ASK, YOU DON'T GET, IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY, WE HAVE NOT
HAD ANY FEEDBACK OR POLICIES AS
IT RELATES TO SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY. THE COORDINATION, FOR
NAVIGATING THIS NEW PROCESS AND
RELATIONSHIPS WITH STATE
AGENCIES CAN BE CHALLENGING,
PARTICULARLY IF THERE'S A LACK
OF CLARITY OF SUPPORT AND
NONPROFITS THAT HAVE HAD NO
PRIOR HISTORY WORKING WITH
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES OR PUBLIC
ENTITIES, AGAIN, THE DISPARITIES
AND THE INEQUITIES AROUND THE
SMALLER NONPROFITS IN CLOSING, I
WOULD JUST SAY ADVANCE PAYMENTS
FROM STATE GRANTS AND CONTRACTS
HAVE PROVEN, PROVEN INVALUABLE
FOR ENHANCING OUR ORGANIZATIONAL
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS.
THEY SUPPORT STABLE OPERATIONS,
IMPROVE FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT,
AND ENSURE THAT OUR PROGRAMS ARE
DELIVERED EFFECTIVELY AND
WITHOUT INTERRUPTIONS. TO FULLY
REALIZE THE POTENTIAL OF AB 590,
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE ADDRESS
THE IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES,
PARTICULARLY THROUGH EDUCATION
AND SUPPORT, BOTH FOR STATE
AGENCIES AND OUR NONPROFIT
PARTNERS. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THESE INSIGHTS AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND OUR FINAL PANELIST, SANDRA
S¼ LEÓN. FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU. CHAIR LIMÓN CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I AM HONORED
TO BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY
REPRESENTING FRESNO, BUILDING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND OUR
GROWING NETWORK OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT ARE WORKING
TO FOSTER AND ENCOURAGE THRIVING
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES CAN LIVE HEALTHY, SAFE,
AND PRODUCTIVE LIVES. FRESNO,
BèC, SERVES AS A CENTRAL TABLE
BRINGING PEOPLE, COMMUNITY, AND
FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TOGETHER TO SHARE KNOWLEDGE,
SKILLS AND RESOURCES TO
COLLECTIVELY ADDRESS AND RESPOND
TO ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
OUR COMMUNITY WHILE DEVELOPING
THE CAPACITY OF EVERYONE
INVOLVED TO BUILD A LONG TERM
FOUNDATION TO ENSURE THAT THE
PEOPLE OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HAVE ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO LIVE HEALTHY AND
THRIVE. IT'S NO SECRET THAT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS ONE OF THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE AGRICULTURAL
REGIONS IN THE WORLD, WITH
NEARLY 2 MILLION ACRES PRODUCING
MORE THAN 350 CROPS AND
CONTRIBUTING OVER 5 BILLION
ANNUALLY TO CALIFORNIA'S GDP.
YET 50% OF RESIDENTS LIVING IN
THE VALLEY STRUGGLE TO MAKE ENDS
MEET. SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR PLAY A MAJOR
ROLE IN HELPING TO SHIFT THIS
STARK REALITY. DURING THE HEIGHT
OF THE PANDEMIC, COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SPECIFICALLY SMALL
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS, ROSE
TO WHAT SEEMED TO BE AN
INSURMOUNTABLE CHALLENGE AND
DISTRIBUTED PREVENTION
INFORMATION, TESTING KITS AND
VACCINATED OVER 25,000 PEOPLE IN
FRESNO COUNTY. THESE EFFORTS
WERE MADE POSSIBLE VIA CONTRACTS
WITH FRESNO COUNTY AND THE CITY
OF FRESNO THAT INCLUDED ADVANCED
PAYMENT PROVISIONS TO ENABLE A
NETWORK OF OVER 17 COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO VERY
QUICKLY HIRE AND DEPLOY 125
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS. THAT
HAPPENED WITHIN 30 DAYS. BEYOND
RAPID RESPONSE SERVICES,
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP. RELIGIOUS SERVICES,
ARTS AND CULTURE, AND OTHER
VITAL SERVICES. ESSENTIAL TO
THRIVING COMMUNITIES, MAKING
THEM ONE OF THE MOST TRUSTED
SECTORS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
NONPROFITS, AS YOU KNOW, ARE
LARGELY FUNDED BY GOVERNMENT
PAYMENTS FOR SERVICES AND
PHILANTHROPY, AND THAT IS WHY
I'M ENCOURAGED BY THE PASSAGE OF
AB 590, WHICH PRIORITIZES
ADVANCE PAYMENTS FOR NONPROFITS
SERVING DISADVANTAGED LOW INCOME
AND UNDER-RESOURCED COMMUNITIES.
TO ENSURE THAT THESE SAME
COMMUNITIES HAVE FAIR AND
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO STATE
CONTRACTS AND GRANTS. IN 2020,
FRESNO BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES SECURED SUCCESSFULLY
SECURED A $6.6 MILLION GRANT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RECREATION TO
RENOVATE RENOVATE CADWELL PARK.
MÐI PARK THAT I GREW UP IN, THAT
IS LOCATED WITHIN A SMALL
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITY IN
FRESNO COUNTY THAT IS HOME TO
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE LIVING IN
ONE OF THE MOST POLLUTED CENSUS
TRACTS IN THE WHOLE STATE. THIS
PARK RENOVATION IS CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY, AND WE ANTICIPATE ITS
FULL COMPLETION IN 2025. THE
PROJECT HAS BEEN MADE POSSIBLE
BY THE CALIFORNIA DROUGHT WATER
PARKS. CLIMATE, COASTAL
PROTECTION AND OUTDOOR ACCESS
FOR ALL ACT OF 2018, KNOWN AS
PROP 68 AND A VERY SPECIFIC
PROVISION WITHIN THAT PROGRAM.
ADVANCE PAYMENTS. WHILE FRESNO,
BèC HAS A BIG PRESENCE, WE DO
NOT HAVE A BIG WALLET, LIKE MANY
OF OUR SISTER ORGANIZATIONS, WE
SPEND DOLLARS AS WE RAISE THEM
AND WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
SUBSIDIZE PROGRAMS THAT PAY US
IN ARREARS. THE COMMON PRACTICE
AMONG STATE AGENCIES TO PAY
CONTRACTS AFTER EXPENSES HAVE
BEEN INCURRED HAS PREVENTED US
FROM PURSUING STATE AND OTHER
GOVERNMENT GRANTS, THE
RENOVATION PROJECT WAS THE FIRST
TIME FRESNO, BèC, PURSUED A
MULTI-MILLION DOLLAR GRANT FROM
THE STATE. WE WOULD NOT HAVE
PURSUED THIS OPPORTUNITY WITHOUT
ADVANCE PAYMENTS, MEANING THAT
OUR COMMUNITY WOULD HAVE MISSED
OUT ON SECURING ITS FAIR SHARE
OF PROP 68 FUNDING. IN FACT, OUR
APPLICATION WAS THE ONLY PROJECT
SELECTED IN FRESNO COUNTY DURING
THAT GRANT CYCLE. I ENCOURAGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO REVIEW THE
PROCEDURES FOR ADVANCE PAYMENTS
WITHIN THAT PROGRAM, TO GLEAN
ITS BEST PRACTICES AND REPLICATE
THEM APPROPRIATELY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB 590, THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION HAS DEVELOPED USER
FRIENDLY FORMS AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ENABLE
EFFICIENCY AND SIMILARLY, WE
HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES THAT HAVE DEVELOPED
CUMBERSOME FORMS AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE OFTEN
DUPLICATIVE AND DIVERT TIME AND
ENERGY FROM THE ACTUAL WORK OF
NONPROFITS CARRYING OUT GOOD
WORK IN THEIR COMMUNITY SHOULD
NOT BE OVERBURDENED BY
UNNECESSARILY COMPLEX
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES. I
OFFER THE FOLLOWING SUGGESTIONS.
ENCOURAGE WIDESPREAD AND
CONSISTENT ADOPTION OF ADVANCE
PAYMENTS ACROSS AGENCIES, GRANTS
AND PROGRAMS. STREAMLINE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES ACROSS
AGENCIES. GRANTS AND PROGRAMS TO
AVOID DUPLICATION AND WASTE.
DEVELOP STANDARDIZED DEFINITIONS
FOR CONTRACTING AND GRANT
LANGUAGE, AND ENSURE THAT
ADVANCE PAYMENTS TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUFFICIENT TO
COVER THE COST OF PROVIDING
SERVICES. RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF IMPORTANT ROLE OF
NONPROFITS IN OUR STATE, IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT POLICYMAKERS
HAVE A COMPLETE UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW NONPROFITS ARE FARING AND
WHAT STEPS NEED TO BE TAKEN TO
STRENGTHEN THIS IMPORTANT
SECTOR. A HEALTHY NONPROFIT
SECTOR IS ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE
ALL PEOPLE CAN THRIVE. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE OUR
EXPERIENCE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED COLLABORATION TO
ENSURE PUBLIC DOLLARS REACH THE
PEOPLE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
OTHER WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS. I'M GOING TO TURN IT
TO MY COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR BORG, GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
OUR PANELISTS FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. I UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
ADVANCED PAYMENTS. AND I AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR MANY OF
THEM IN ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO PROCURE OTHER FUNDING,
ESPECIALLY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I HAVE FOR
YOU IS WITHIN THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE ADVANCED PAYMENTS, HAS
THERE BEEN ANY CONSIDERATION OR
REQUIREMENTS THAT CATERED TO
FINANCIAL PLANNING, FINANCIAL
LITERACY BY OUR NONPROFITS AS
THEY CONSIDER OR APPLY FOR,
PREPAYMENTS OR ADVANCE PAYMENTS?
I KNOW, AND LET ME PUT A LITTLE
CONTEXT, I SHOULD HAVE PUT A
LITTLE CONTEXT IN THERE. SO I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S, SCHOOLS THAT
ARE POPPING UP WITH REGARD TO
TRAINING AND HOW TO DO
NONPROFITS, BUT NOT I DON'T
BELIEVE WE'VE HAD PRIOR TO THE
SCHOOLS COMING FORWARD. AND I'M
NOT SURE WHAT I'VE NEVER REALLY
LOOKED INTO THE TRAINING FOR OUR
NONPROFITS, BUT I'M PRETTY SURE
THAT THEY DO HAVE A COMPONENT
WHEN IT COMES TO FINANCIAL
PLANNING OR FINANCIAL LITERACY.
BUT FOR THOSE THAT COME UP
WITHOUT THAT TYPE OF TRAINING OR
FORMAL TRAINING, IS THERE ANY
REQUIREMENT OR ANY EXPECTATION
WHEN APPLYING FOR THESE THESE
TYPES OF PAYMENTS OR FUNDING TO
HAVE A REQUIREMENT OF FINANCIAL
LITERACY OR PLANNING AS THEY
MOVE FORWARD WITH THEIR
NONPROFITS? SO IN OUR
EXPERIENCE, THOSE TWO THINGS
AREN'T TIED TOGETHER. THAT IS
CERTAINLY TRUE, THAT THERE IS AN
EMERGENCE OF MORE TRAINING
PROGRAMS, SCHOOLS,
CERTIFICATIONS, CREDENTIALS OF
ALL VARIOUS TYPES, SOME OF THEM
SEATED IN ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS,
MOST OF THEM ACTUALLY STILL
SEATED IN OTHER NONPROFITS,
FUNDERS ARE CERTAINLY DOING THIS
AS WELL. AND OFFERING THOSE
RESOURCES. BUT THAT AND TO MY
KNOWLEDGE, HAS NOT BEEN TIED TO
SOMETHING LIKE ADVANCE PAYMENT,
SO, SO JUST AS A GENERAL NEED
FOR THE SECTOR TO DO GOOD
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT, THAT'S
CERTAINLY OUT THERE. AND THOSE,
THOSE RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE,
BUT THAT HASN'T BEEN TIED TO
GRANTS, EVEN EVEN MORE
TRADITIONAL GRANTS. THAT'S
USUALLY NOT PART OF A
REQUIREMENT PER SE. IS THERE A
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
SOME SORT OF LEVEL OF FINANCIAL
PLANNING OR FINANCIAL LITERACY
AS A REQUIREMENT, AS APPLICANTS
APPLY FOR FUNDING OR PREPAYMENT?
I MEAN, MY, MY OFF THE CUFF
ANSWER WOULD BE, I DON'T THINK
SO. I DON'T SEE THAT THAT IS A
PARTICULAR NEED IN THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR. I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW,
AS WE HEARD IN THE PRIOR PANEL,
THE OVERSIGHT AND THE
TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS AROUND
HOW EVERY DOLLAR IS USED IN THE
SECTOR IS CERTAINLY ROBUST, TO
SAY THE LEAST. SO THERE'S A GOOD
DEAL OF REPORTING AND PLANNING
FOR HOW EVERY DOLLAR GETS, GETS
USED. AND OF COURSE, FOR ANY
GRANT OR CONTRACT, THERE'S
ALWAYS SOME REPORTING
REQUIREMENT WITH A VERY FEW RARE
EXCEPTIONS. SO I THINK THAT THE
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CAPACITY
INTERNAL TO A NONPROFIT TO DO
THAT. AGAIN, MOST NONPROFIT
LEADERS ARE SEEKING THAT ANYWAY.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF PEER
LEARNING AS WELL WITHIN THE
SECTOR. THAT HAPPENS VERY OFTEN.
SO I DON'T I THINK I WOULDN'T
RECOMMEND ADDING ONE MORE
REQUIREMENT TO, FOR EXAMPLE,
BEFORE YOU SEEK THIS GRANT, YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THAT CREDENTIAL,
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF INCENTIVE
TO HAVE GOOD PLANNING AND GOOD
REPORTING BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THE
CONSEQUENCE IF YOU DON'T IS THAT
THAT REVENUE DOESN'T COME OUT,
DOESN'T COME AS AS A SECOND
OPPORTUNITY OR, OR IN SOME CASES
CAN BE REVOKED. I MEAN, IT
DEPENDS ON THE ARRANGEMENT. IF
YOU LOOK AT THE OVERALL REVENUE
STREAMS IN THE SECTOR, THE
ACTUAL LARGEST REVENUE STREAM IN
THE SECTOR, IF YOU COUNT ALL OF
IT TOGETHER, IS EARNED INCOME.
THE SECOND LARGEST IS GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS AND GRANTS. AND THEN
THE THIRD IS PHILANTHROPY. BUT
THE MAJORITY OF THAT IS
INDIVIDUAL DONORS. SO EACH OF
THOSE POTENTIAL REVENUE SOURCES
ARE DOING THEIR OWN DUE
DILIGENCE ON, YOU KNOW, CAN I DO
I HAVE FAITH AND CONFIDENCE IN
THIS NONPROFIT TO MANAGE THE
DOLLARS THAT I GIVE? THERE'S A
HANDFUL OF STANDARDIZED
REPORTING, LIKE FUNCTIONAL
EXPENSE REPORTS. YOU KNOW, HOW
MUCH OF THIS IS GOING TO CORE
PROGRAM, HOW MUCH OF THIS IS
GOING TO ADMINISTRATIVE EFFORT,
HOW MUCH OF THIS IS GOING TO
FUNDRAISING? BUT THERE'S A LOT
GREATER DETAIL THAT IS OFTEN
ASKED BY INDIVIDUALS. AND IT
JUST DEPENDS ON WHAT THE WHO THE
REVENUE SOURCE IS. BUT WE DON'T
HAVE A STANDARD REQUIREMENT.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE STANDARD NÓ
FOR THE STATE. NO. OKAY. IF I
COULD JUST SAY, SO I'M A
CAPACITY BUILDING ORGANIZATION.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR TEN YEARS. WE KNOW THAT, YOU
KNOW, THE INLAND EMPIRE
SPECIFICALLY HAD KIND OF BEEN
KNOWN AS AN AREA THAT WE LACKED
CAPACITY TO COME AFTER DOLLARS.
AND WERE COMPLETE. AND WE'RE
ALSO DEMONSTRATED THAT WE'RE
UNDERFUNDED IN THE REGION, BOTH
IN PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS AND IN
STATE FUNDING. SO WE'VE
RECOGNIZED THAT WE HAD TO CHANGE
THE NARRATIVE AROUND NONPROFITS.
AND HAVING CAPACITY OR NOT. AND
MOST NOTABLY, NONPROFIT LEADERS
OF COLOR. SO WE PROVIDE YEAR
LONG CAPACITY BUILDING ACADEMIES
FOR SMALLER NONPROFITS. LEADERS
OF COLOR TO COME THROUGH
PROJECTS. AND WE HAVE TO GO FIND
FUNDING FOR THAT TO HAPPEN, FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO STRENGTHEN AND
BUILD SUSTAINABILITY WITHIN OUR
SECTOR. SO TO JEFF'S POINT, SOME
FOUNDATIONS OFFER CAPACITY
BUILDING, BUT THE MAJORITY DO
NOT, AND IT'S BEEN INCUMBENT ON
OUR OWN SECTOR AND OURSELVES,
OUR RESILIENCE. OR I'LL SAY OUR
TENACITY IS THAT WE RECOGNIZE WE
GRADUATE A GROUP OF TEN
NONPROFITS EVERY YEAR, AND THOSE
TEN COME BACK AND HELP THE NEXT
TEN. THAT'S OUR MODEL, BUT THERE
IS A LOT OF OTHER CAPACITY
BUILDING OPPORTUNITIES, BUT NOT
GENERALLY TIED TO SPECIFIC
FUNDING STREAMS. I DO WANT TO
ADD THAT I THINK, I DON'T THINK
THE ISSUE FROM MY EXPERIENCE IS
FINANCIAL PLANNING FROM THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR. IT'S REALLY
HARD TO PLAN WHEN YOU'RE WORKING
WITH THE STATE AGENCY THAT DOES
NOT PROVIDE TIMELY PAYMENTS. SO
WE'VE HAD EXPERIENCES WITH
CONTRACTS THAT WE HAVE ENTERED
INTO ARREARS WHERE THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT WE WILL
RECEIVE PAYMENTS WITHIN 90 DAYS,
AND WE ACTUALLY DO NOT RECEIVE
PAYMENTS AFTER SIX MONTHS OR
LONGER. AND SO THAT, YOU KNOW,
NO MATTER HOW GOOD I AM AT MY
CASH FLOW PROJECTIONS, IF THE
DOLLARS DON'T ACTUALLY COME IN,
IT REALLY PUTS A STRAIN ON OUR
ORGANIZATION. WHEN WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING SURE THAT
WE PAY OUR VENDORS AND OUR
EMPLOYEES RIGHT WITHIN A 30 DAY
PERIOD. AND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT I THINK ARE
SYSTEMIC, THAT I WOULD ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGE, THAT WE FIND SYSTEMIC
SOLUTIONS TO, BECAUSE BY THE
TIME NONPROFITS ARE GOING AFTER
STATE DOLLARS, THEY WILL HAVE
ALREADY BEEN IN EXISTENCE,
RIGHT? AND HAVE GONE THROUGH A
COUPLE OF CYCLES OF MAKING SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THEIR NINE 90S
COMPLETED, THAT THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH AUDITS BECAUSE ALL OF
THOSE ARE PARTS OF OUR
REQUIREMENTS OF MOST GRANT
APPLICATIONS, WHETHER THEY'RE
THROUGH GOVERNMENT OR PRIVATE
SECTORS. SO I THINK THE
CHALLENGE REALLY IS ON
REIMBURSEMENTS AND WHEN CAN WE
ACTUALLY REALISTICALLY EXPECT
THOSE. AND MORE IMPORTANTLY,
THAT THEY'RE TIMELY? THAT'S
RIGHT. ON ON GETTING THEM RIGHT.
AND I WILL ADD, I'M LOOKING AT
TEXT RIGHT NOW OF AB 590 THAT IN
ADDITION, THERE'S SOME BASIC
MINIMUM REQUIREMENT REQUIREMENT
IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
ADVANCE PAYMENT, WHICH IS ONE,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A BUDGET TO YOU
HAVE TO SUPPORT DOCUMENTATION,
FOR THE NEED FOR AN ADVANCE
PAYMENT, THREE IS TO OF COURSE,
BE IN GOOD STANDING, WHICH WAS
OUR FIRST PANEL. AND THEN FOUR
IS, YOU KNOW, INSURANCE AND SO,
THERE ARE IT'S NOT IF A
NONPROFIT WEREN'T, THEY COULD
NOT BE ELIGIBLE IF THEY DIDN'T
MEET THESE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS
TO SAFEGUARD SOME OF I THINK
WHAT YOU'VE RAISED ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, DO THEY HAVE THE
INFORMATION. ARE THEY YOU KNOW,
SET READY, SET, GO RIGHT FOR
THIS. SO I JUST WANTED TO ADD
THAT. THANK YOU. AND I'M GOING
TO TURN IT TO OUR CO-CHAIR. YEAH
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
PANELISTS. THIS HAS BEEN SO
IMPORTANT TO SHARE THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU HAVE. THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL, YOU
KNOW, LEADING FROM WITHIN THE
STATE GOVERNMENT TO TRY AND
ENCOURAGE ADVANCE PAYMENTS AND
USING THE EXPERIENCE THAT YOU'VE
HAD AND THE TRAINING TO EXPAND
THAT INFORMATION TO OTHER STATE
AGENCIES, BOTH OF THE NONPROFIT
LEADERS HERE, YOU KNOW, HAVE
REALLY MADE THE CASE SO STRONGLY
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE EQUITY
THAT'S REQUIRED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE AGENCIES AND THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH ARE ABLE TO DO THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO
TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THE VERY SMALL NONPROFITS THAT
YOU SPOKE ABOUT IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE, 67% TO DOCTOR JACKSON'S
POINT THAT, YOU KNOW, WE SHOULD
BE REALLY GETTING OUT OF THE WAY
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
TRYING TO DO THE WORK AND
SUPPORTING THAT WORK THROUGH OUR
STATE PROCESSES, RATHER THAN
MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
ACCESS FUNDING AND TO DO THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING. SO WELL
ON A DAILY BASIS. I'M REALLY
INSPIRED AND I'M REMINDED, BY
MR. GREEN'S COMMENTS AT THE
BEGINNING ABOUT THE NONPROFIT
EQUITY INITIATIVE AND ALL THE
OTHER LEGISLATION THAT WAS, DID
NOT, UNFORTUNATELY, MAKE ITS WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS. BUT WE NEED
TO REDOUBLE OUR EFFORTS AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE CONTRACTING
REFORMS THAT WERE PART OF THAT
PACKAGE ARE PASSED INTO LAW, AND
THAT THE ADVANCE PAYMENT
LEGISLATION IS EQUITABLY AND
AGGRESSIVELY, INTEGRATED INTO
ALL STATE AGENCIES AND
PROCESSES. THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO DO. AND I'M CURIOUS, ARE
THERE, STATE COMMUNICATION TOOLS
THAT WE COULD BE BETTER
UTILIZING TO SPREAD THE SUCCESS
STORIES? YOU MENTIONED THE
EXAMPLES OF THE AGENCIES THAT
ARE USING ADVANCE PAYMENT AND
HAVING THEM WORK SUCCESSFULLY,
USING BEING CHEERLEADERS FOR
THAT EFFORT AND SPREADING THE
WORD, YOU KNOW, AGENCY BY AGENCY
ABOUT SUCCESS STORIES. YOU KNOW,
WHAT WHAT STRATEGIES DO YOU
THINK WOULD BE EFFECTIVE FOR US
TO ENGAGE IN TO TRY AND GET THE
ADMINISTRATION TO HELP SPREAD
THE WORD THAT THIS IS A GREAT
IDEA, THAT WE SHOULD ONLY BE
DOING MORE OF. I WOULD LOOK TO
OUR AGENCY LEADERSHIP TO ADVISE
ON THAT. I DON'T CLAIM TO BE THE
EXPERT THERE, BUT I CERTAINLY
KNOW THAT THERE'S INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE STATE TO USE AS PLATFORMS
FOR THAT. SO WE WOULD CERTAINLY
BE SUPPORTIVE OF IT. YEAH, I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR ALL OF OUR STATE
AGENCIES. I CAN SPEAK FOR WHAT
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL IS
DOING AND HOW WE INTEGRATE
CAPACITY BUILDING ACROSS THE
COUNCIL MEMBERS. SO THERE'S
DEFINITELY WAYS TO CONTINUE TO
COMMUNICATE WHAT'S WORKING,
WHAT'S NOT WORKING. AND WE DO
THAT REGULARLY WITH AT LEAST ONE
OF OUR COUNCIL MEETINGS IN A
PUBLIC FORUM TO DISCUSS HOW OUR
CAPACITY BUILDING IS, WHAT ARE
THE STRATEGIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED? SUCCESS NONSUCCESS
AND BRINGING IN SOME OF OUR
GRANTEES. SO AGAIN, THAT'S A
THAT'S A PUBLIC FORUM THAT CAN
BE DONE, AND WE CAN DEFINITELY
SHARE WHAT OTHER AGENCIES ARE
DOING IN THAT SPACE. WELL, I
THINK YOU ARE LEADING THE EFFORT
FROM WITHIN. AND I THINK WE WANT
TO AMPLIFY, YOU KNOW, THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING TO ENCOURAGE
OTHER STATE AGENCIES TO
RECOGNIZE, YOU KNOW, THE
BENEFITS OF ADVANCE PAY AND ALSO
TO BE ADVOCATES THEMSELVES FOR
THE THINGS THAT LEÓN MENTIONED,
THE STREAMLINING OF THE
PROCESSES, THE STANDARDIZED
DEFINITIONS, YOU KNOW, ALL THE
THINGS THAT JUST MAKE THIS MORE
PRACTICAL AND EFFECTIVE AND HELP
TO LEVERAGE THE DOLLARS THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE FOR THE SERVICES
THAT YOU'RE PROVIDING TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. WELL,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO THE
PANEL. I APPRECIATE THIS. I
THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
MEANINGFUL PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
BUT I THINK THE ROLLOUT OF IT
ALSO IS IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS WHAT IS NOT HAPPENING,
IT'S VERY NEW. SO I ALSO EXPECT
THAT THE ROLLOUT WILL IMPROVE,
WITH TIME AS WE'RE ABLE TO I
THINK, IDENTIFY THIS. AND I
THINK WHAT I, YOU KNOW, WHAT I'M
HEARING ARE CO-CHAIRS SAY AND
JUST MEMBERS SAY IS ONE THAT
EVEN WHILE IT'S NEW LEGISLATION,
WE'RE REALLY INTERESTED IN
HEARING THE FEEDBACK TO HELP US
ENSURE THAT THE DEPARTMENTS THAT
THE AGENCIES INVOLVED ALSO HAVE
THE INFORMATION, BECAUSE THAT
THEN GETS, SHARED WITH, OF
COURSE, OUR NONPROFITS
THEMSELVES. IN BOTH THE FIRST
PANEL AND THE SECOND PANEL, I
THINK THAT THERE WERE STRONG
THEMES OF, YOU KNOW, WHAT
HAPPENED, WHAT THE LAWS THAT ARE
HERE AND HOW THEY ARE FELT AND
INTERPRETED AND RECEIVED, ON THE
GROUND. THERE'S ALSO A
RECOGNITION THAT, YOU KNOW,
CAPACITY IS SUPER DIFFERENT,
BETWEEN, YOU KNOW, DOCTOR
JACKSON SAID, WHAT A NONPROFIT
OF ONE PERSON WORKING THERE WITH
A $50,000 BUDGET CAN DO TO YOU
KNOW, A REALLY HUGE NONPROFITS.
AND SO I THINK WE STILL HAVE
SOME WORK TO DO IN THAT SPACE AS
A LEGISLATURE TO ACTUALLY FIGURE
OUT HOW TO CRAFT LAWS AND
LEGISLATION THAT ACCOUNT FOR,
LIKE, THE HUGE DIFFERENCE IN
NONPROFITS IN OUR STATE. WE HAVE
A LOT OF THEM. WE CONSTANTLY
TALK ABOUT THAT. BUT WHAT A
NONPROFIT OF ONE CAN DO IS
REALLY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT A
NONPROFIT OF 100 CAN DO, RIGHT?
AND I THINK IN THE SPACES WE
NAVIGATE, WE DON'T ACTUALLY
OFTENTIMES INTERACT WITH
NONPROFITS. YOU KNOW, WE DO
INTERACT WITH NONPROFITS OF 100,
BUT WE TEND TO INTERACT WITH
NONPROFITS THAT ARE SMALLER,
THAT, YOU KNOW, ARE A HANDFUL OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING TO BE
THE, YOU KNOW, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR, THE COMPLIANCE PERSON,
THE TAX PERSON, THE VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZER, YOU KNOW, THE WEB
PERSON, THE IT PERSON. AND SO
THAT IS WHERE I THINK IT GETS
HARD. AND I JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
DOING THIS WORK, BUT THIS TYPE
OF FEEDBACK IS REALLY HELPFUL TO
US. SO I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU
TRAVELING FROM ALL PARTS OF THE
STATE TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
INFORM US. SO THANK YOU. AND NOW
WE WILL OPEN IT UP FOR A PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND SO I INVITE ANY
FOLKS THAT HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD, STATE
YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION, AND
JUST, YOU KNOW, YOUR COMMENT
ALTOGETHER. THANK YOU. SANDRA
BORRERO ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA, WE WOULD SUPPORT
PROVIDING DOJ WITH MORE
RESOURCES TO STREAMLINE AND
UPDATE THEIR PROCESS. MAYBE THEY
NEED MORE STAFF SUPPORT TO
SUPPORT COMPLIANCE. WE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SEE NONPROFIT
EMPLOYEE PAY DATA AVAILABLE
ONLINE. SEIU REPRESENTS
NONPROFIT WORKERS, AND WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE INDUSTRY
OVERALL, AND WE WOULD THINK THAT
PROVIDING THIS PAY TRANSPARENCY
WOULD HELP TO RAISE THE
STANDARDS. AND IT WOULD ALSO
ALLOW US TO MONITOR WHETHER OR
NOT THE WAGES OF NONPROFIT
EMPLOYEES ARE UNDERCUTTING
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS, WHICH
LOWERS THE STANDARDS FOR
EVERYONE, AND I JUST WANT TO ADD
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF NONPROFITS
WORKS. THEY DO SOME WORK THAT
GOVERNMENT CANNOT DO. RIGHT. BUT
THERE'S ALSO OFTEN TIMES WHEN
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE DOING SOME
OF THIS WORK. AND WE WANT TO
LOOK FOR WAYS TO ENCOURAGE
GOVERNMENTS TO TAKE THESE
SERVICES IN-HOUSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, GOOD AFTERNOON.
CO-CHAIRS LEMON AND HEART. I'M
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA, SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF A NONPROFIT
BASED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
CALLED HAPPY TRAILS FOR KIDS.
THE MISSION OF THAT ORGANIZATION
IS TO PROVIDE ENRICHMENT FOR
CHILDREN WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
FOSTER CARE BY OFFERING COST
FREE OUTDOOR, EDUCATIONAL AND
OVERNIGHT CAMPING EXPERIENCES
THAT REALLY PROMOTE THE
IMPORTANCE OF PERMANENCY,
HAPPINESS, FRIENDSHIP, AND ROLE
MODELS. AND I WANTED TO SHARE AN
EXPERIENCE THAT THE NONPROFIT
EXPERIENCED THIS YEAR WITH THE
TOPIC THAT WAS DISCUSSED UNDER
PANEL ONE, AND NOT UNLIKE THE
STORY THAT YOU HEARD FROM MR.
JONES, I THINK I CERTAINLY HAVE
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
WORKLOAD AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
ARE FACED AT THE CHARITY JUST IN
TERMS OF PARTICULARLY DURING
THESE PERIODS OF SURGES. BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
PANEL HEAR FROM ANOTHER
NONPROFIT, PROFIT, ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCE, HAPPY TRAILS. DID
EXPERIENCE A LAPSE IN COMPLIANCE
EARLIER IN THIS YEAR, AND IT
CAME AT A TIME WHEN WE WERE VERY
CLOSE TO, HAVING GRANT
SOLICITATIONS COME TO FRUITION.
SO IT WAS AT THIS PRECISE TIME
WHEN THE DELINQUENT STATUS WAS
DISCOVERED. OF COURSE, HAPPY
TRAILS RESPONDED IMMEDIATELY.
ONCE THEY WERE INFORMED OF THE
PROBLEM, THEY SUBMITTED THE
NEEDED PAYMENT AND
DOCUMENTATION, BUT IT WAS
DIFFICULT TO ASCERTAIN IN OUR
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE REGISTRY
ABOUT WHAT WAS MISSING, AND IT
TOOK NEARLY THREE MONTHS THAT
LAPSED BETWEEN THE TIME WE WERE
NOTIFIED, AND THE PUBLIC FACING
WEBSITE BEING UPDATED. AND OF
COURSE, GRANTERS REQUIRE AN
UPDATED AND COMPLIANT STATUS
BEFORE THEY ARE WILLING TO
PROVIDE FUNDING AND DONATIONS,
OUR I'M GOING TO ASK YOU JUST TO
WRAP UP YOUR COMMENTS. JUST
BECAUSE IT'S PUBLIC, I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT JUST TO FOCUS ON
THE MODERNIZATION, ENHANCED
COMMUNICATION AND PROCESS
SIMPLIFICATION. WE FOUND IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO FIND A LIVE PERSON
TO SPEAK TO, TO GET UPDATES
DURING THIS PROCESS, AND IT
WOULD HAVE REALLY RELIEVED A LOT
OF STRESS AND DISCOMFORT DURING
THIS PERIOD OF DELINQUENCY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. YVONNE FERNANDEZ
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF LABOR UNIONS. WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK DONE BY NONPROFITS. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR TRUSTED
COMMUNITY PARTNERS, AS STATED BY
MY COLLEAGUE REPRESENTING SEIU,
WE URGE MEMBERS TO WORK TOWARDS
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY FOR
EMPLOYEE SALARY INFORMATION, TO
CONTRACT INFORMATION. THIS WILL
LEAD TO GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR ALL MEMBERS OF THE SERVICE
DELIVERY PROCESS AS FOUNDATIONAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS. STATE PUBLIC
SECTOR WORKERS MAKE UP THE
BACKBONE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
ECONOMY. WE ARE OPEN TO
PARTNERING WITH THE STATE TO
FOCUS ON GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY,
EFFECTIVENESS, AND WORKER
EQUITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'M ABIGAIL SHARON, AND I'M ONE
OF THOSE SMALL ORGANIZATIONS WHO
DOES EVERYTHING. SO, MY
NONPROFIT IS THE SERVANT
MINISTRIES, WORKING IN A SECTOR
OF HOMELESSNESS, HELPING THE
HOMELESS, FEEDING THEM, BLAH,
BLAH, BLAH, AND SO FORTH. JUST
TRY TO REMIND THEM THAT THEY'RE
STILL HUMAN, THAT WE SEE THEM,
THAT WE CARE. AND ALSO AT THE
SAME TIME, IN 2023, I OPENED A
LEGAL AID CLINIC THAT SERVES THE
UNDOCUMENTED. SO WE OFFER PRO
BONO AND LOW BONO SERVICES.
HOWEVER, SOMETIMES WITH TEARS IN
MY EYES, I HAVE TO CHARGE MY
CLIENTS BECAUSE IF I DON'T
CHARGE THEM, WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE OFFICE. AND SO TODAY I
WANT TO ADDRESS THE AREA OF
COMMUNICATION TO THE AGENCIES
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO SUPPORT THE
NONPROFIT, ESPECIALLY THE SMALL
ONES. WE DON'T GET INFORMATION
AT ALL. AND WE NEED TO CREATE
BETTER TOOLS SO THAT WE ARE WELL
INFORMED OF RESOURCES THAT ARE
OUT THERE THAT WE CAN GET. AND
PEOPLE THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
SUPPORT THE SMALL ORGANIZATIONS.
SO IT'S VERY HARD TO GET
RESOURCES. IT'S ALMOST LIKE A
RESOURCES ARE DISTRIBUTED WITHIN
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
EXERCISING AS A NONPROFIT FOR
DECADES AND SO FORTH, GRANTS THE
SAME THING BECAUSE THEY ARE WELL
VERSED IN WRITING GRANTS. OF
COURSE, THEY'RE GOING TO GET
THEM. AND WE JUST STARTED, WHICH
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO WRITE
A GRANT. SO WE JUST WRITE
WHATEVER WHAT WE CAN. WE NEVER
GATHERED THEM. I NEVER EVEN
GOTTEN ONE GRANT, EVER. SO IT'S
A VERY, VERY, VERY HARD. I'M
SURPRISED THERE IS AGENCIES THAT
SUPPOSEDLY SUPPORT,
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS OURS, BUT
THEY DO NOT INFORM US OF WHAT
THEY DO OR WHAT THEY CAN OFFER.
SO THE SECRETARY OF STATE
DATABASE IS VERY ROBUST AND
EFFECTIVE. WHY NOT USE THOSE
INFORMATION TO SPREAD OUT THE
WORD OF WHAT'S OUT THERE OR
TRAININGS OR SO FORTH TO SUPPORT
OR GRANTS OR OPPORTUNITIES TO
SUPPORT SMALL ORGANIZATIONS? I
THINK COMMUNICATION AREA NEED TO
BE IMPROVED AND ALSO WHERE TO
FIND RESOURCES AND SO FORTH. SO
THAT'S ALL I WANTED TO
CONTRIBUTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT, I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THOSE WHO HAVE TAKEN
THEIR TIME TO COME TO PRESENT TO
US ON THE PANEL, BUT ALSO TO
GIVE US PUBLIC COMMENT. I WANT
TO, OFFER SOME CLOSING REMARKS,
TO OUR CO-CHAIR. WELL, I JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS MY THANKS AND
GRATITUDE FOR EVERYBODY WHO CAME
AND TESTIFIED TODAY, THE
HIGHLIGHTING OF THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR THROUGH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE, IN BOTH HOUSES, I
THINK IS EXTREMELY VALUABLE. IT
HELPS ADVANCE THE COMMUNICATION
ISSUES THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER. AND BRINGS
TOGETHER THE SHARED EXPERIENCES
THAT AGENCIES AND INDIVIDUALS
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO
SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES,
EXPERIENCE TRYING TO WORK WITH
STATE AGENCIES TO BE MORE
EFFECTIVE. AND THAT WILL HELP
SHARPEN OUR ABILITY TO CREATE
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES. AND THIS IS THE EXACT
REASON WE HAVE THIS COMMITTEE
AND REALLY JUST APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY WHO'S PARTICIPATING IN
THAT PROCESS. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT, WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND ADJOURN
OUR SUB HEARING OR NON PROFIT
HEARING. OUR SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING THERE YOU GO. TAKE CARE.